[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome welcome everybody i can promise
you one thing and that's the that is
there's gonna be some technical
difficulties
i promise but we are here
all right i'm a permanent smile that's
just the way it is it'll probably switch
it up in a second um
but i am super happy to be here with
peter france ian hubert and ren
wykman guys we are freaking doing it so
first off do we sound okay can you guys
give me some levels how are we sounding
how we looking hello hello
hey how you doing
i'm doing great i'm excited for this i
mean
so much creativity so much inspiration
here in this little
little area right now and i i could not
be more excited agreed man
yeah um so if i could get my video fixed
you know that would be sick but right
now i hope i'm sounding good
um we'll figure this out in a minute
and this this this is how i know you as
clint just
permanently constant good vibes all
around um
but yeah guys so
well basically we got a lot of
announcements we got a lot of freaking
announcements but it would freaking help
if my camera was working let's see let's
see if i can't
frickin it was working it was the whole
time
all the technical difficulties we've had
up to this point has been a
hoot it's been a good time but hey i
appreciate you guys
doing this with me um this is going to
be an incredible stream
oh and peter peter by the way is like
on some next level because he's like
taking over that chat
you know his video is constantly popping
in and out
okay i can't see it now i'm watching the
stream oh no
it's about hilarious
i ruled this live stream
all right well maybe my video will fix
itself eventually at some point but guys
couple announcements here's what we're
going to do so first off myself
and the discord moderators went through
2401 submissions
you guys submitted it was freaking
insane the renders were nuts if you
total up the collective hours it's 18
years
worth of renders it's absolutely
ridiculous
a lot of time that's insane yeah it's
absolutely absurd
um that's that's about
that's a little a little more than half
a billion
seconds yeah it's uh it's a lot
it is certainly a lot which is a lot
geez
so you know myself the discord mods we
went through everything we picked the
top 100
and try to keep it as unbiased as
possible and then i got together with
these guys
um a couple days ago we went through the
top 100
and we whittled it down and we found our
top five
we're not telling you yet until the end
of this thing
but um that's what we're gonna do during
the stream we're gonna get this down to
the top five i basically issued
everybody
a little animation you guys built it out
in your style you put you know
put your spice on it built out your
world and five you guys are going to be
going home with some amazing
stuff so fifth place um let's go through
these prizes really quick
whoa hold up that was an earthquake i
just felt a nerf really
okay sorry yeah but my i was shaking i'm
outside on the ground and i'm like
shaking
are you in san diego okay sorry okay
uh just north of san diego yeah i'm next
to a big lake outside of san diego
anyway yeah that was wild um
sorry continue so yeah basically i'm
gonna go through these prizes i gotta
give a shout out to
rococo to wacom to pny to aftershocks
and to quixo for hooking up
all of the prizes for this thing fifth
place
let's see man this is off the top of the
dome here fifth place
is getting um an awesome pny
ssd as well as a one-year subscription
to the quicksilver megascans library
it's gonna be the same for fourth and
fifth place all right but as soon as you
go up
to third place if you're if your render
is the third best render in this whole
thing you're gonna get both of those
things you're gonna get the quixote mega
scans
subscription you're gonna get the pny an
even better pny ssd
and you're also going to get a wacom
tablet um
a size of your choice you know small
medium large whatever you want um
shout outs to wacom those guys are
amazing and then also
second place you get all of that plus a
pair of aftershocks
um like open ear headphones the things
that we use all the time i use these
things all the time they're the best
and first place gets all of that the
open ear headphones from raptor shocks
the wacom tablet size of your choice
p and y uh ssd the kwiks will make skins
year long subscription and the rococo
full mocap suit with the gloves and the
studio
all that stuff so it's gonna be nuts
it's gonna be freaking crazy
peter's all tiny again at least at least
you're not taking over
the visual like there you go you're
fixed now
so yeah um so
any other announcements i just want to
thank everybody for doing this
um for everyone who submitted to you
guys for helping me
uh judge this thing um
what else uh i just wanna say
that what i've seen so far i've seen the
top 100
and every single one of them is amazing
like legitimately incredible i was blown
away
yeah it's uh i'm excited to look at all
of them with everyone it's freaking nuts
um any and just scale of this thing too
like i
over the past month i've seen the entire
3d community explode
i feel like it's really good together in
a cool way
like you should be really proud of
yourself clint for being able to inspire
so many people to come together like
this this is really cool this is really
special dude i'm
so inspired that like i feel like i just
can't move
you know like i'm just i'm i'm frozen
out of shock
and like it's blowing my mind
and guys my goodness um next weekend
here we're gonna be we're gonna have a
top 100
like all the ones that we're gonna
review today there's gonna be a montage
of the top hundred
my buddy adam he goes by feverkin he did
like two custom tracks for it and then
on the same day i'll also release the
full 2401 cut
and that's gonna be everything it's
gonna be three and a half hours long
it's gonna be nuts three and a half
hours yeah
just like solid vibes and good shots
[Laughter]
absolutely um okay so i think that's
everything
uh let's see let me go through my notes
here
oh yeah really glad that uh i got this
holly
holly land like mic right now uh they
sent one over
and i'm glad you guys can hear me you
can't see me but shout outs
you sound you sound great that's good
that's it doesn't even matter we can't
see yeah
friggin good heck yeah i don't need to
see you
hearing is enough all right so here's
what we're gonna do
here's what we're gonna do um we're
gonna go through these top hundred
we're gonna whittle that down to the top
75.
all right from there we're going to go
top 50 from that 75 from that top 50
we're going to go
top 25 from the top 25 we're gonna go
top 15 and from the top 15 we are going
to choose
the five best renders out of all 2401
renders
now we like i said we've done this so we
you know
we've gone through this process we know
who the winners are but we don't know
who's first second third fourth or fifth
so we're going to figure that out live
with y'all it's gonna be crazy um
so before we begin
shout out to skillshare you know
so i think i'm gonna have to hit this
button right here i'm gonna show you
talk to you guys a little about
skillshare for a second yeah and then
we're gonna get into it all right i'll
see you guys in two seconds
talk soon this week's stream is brought
to you by our friends over at skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community for creatives like you guys
who are looking to up their game
grow their value and learn a new skill
now it doesn't matter if you're a
beginner
intermediate or advanced on your journey
you can learn
anything here on skillshare at any level
and any
schedule type too because these classes
come in bite-size little chunks
sometimes 5-10 minutes and it'll allow
you to fit it into your very busy
schedule
alright so first i gotta shout out this
incredible artist this guy is don
mupassi
known as visual don he's an incredible
artist he's gonna teach you guys how to
make a looping city animation in c4d
and after effects this guy is awesome
the work he puts out in c4d
is incredible and i know you guys are
going to learn a ton with his tutorials
on skillshare
next up i know we got some blender folks
up in here so i don't want to forget
about you guys blender is a free program
it is a fantastic program if you guys
are looking to dive in and learn how to
do stuff for free
and there's a ton of great tutorials on
skillshare for blender and this one here
is an intro to modeling so if you guys
are trying to
learn more about how modeling works what
it is this is a great way to start
for anyone trying to do this for free
and finally for anyone trying to bite
off more than they can chew
there is a ridiculous 11 hour course on
how to make a game
here on skillshare it's a fantastic
course lots to learn here
and unreal engine is again it's free
guys so check out this fun course on
skillshare it's a good time so as a
skillshare member you guys get unlimited
access to regularly updated premium
content
for less than 9.99 a month for a yearly
subscription and to the first thousand
people who click the link in the
description
i got you guys with a free trial of a
skillshare
premium membership you guys are going to
learn something new
you're going to grow you're going to get
past the competition and it also helps
me out too it helps me do more of these
live streams so click the link in the
description
and start learning all right
okay so we're back uh i think that went
like one and a half times over
but hey like i said you know lots of
things going on in the stream today
i'm fixed i can see myself uh
definitely oh my god the chat is going
crazy
thanks for thanks for bearing with us
guys uh hans thanks for the super chat
man i appreciate you
there's like 80 million plates i'm
juggling trying to run this stream at
the same time with all these
things going on so thank you guys for
bearing with me thanks for hopping in
and joining us today we're going to go
through all these awesome renders and
check them out so
peter you brought up a good point dude
um
yeah yeah i was just saying that you
know we're going to be whittling
these renders down to the top 75 top 50
top 25 top
15 10 5 whatever and i just wanted to
say
that all of these renders are amazing
like i hope nobody's upset that we're
skipping past theirs going to the top 75
or 50 because being in the top 100
already out of 2 000 is crazy
so i just want to congratulate everybody
on being in the top 100
absolutely let's see uh
100 that's doing some math
that's funny yeah no it's true it's true
we're already looking at the top four
percent
heck like if you're here you're already
like the cream of the crop here and it's
like
it don't eat don't take anything
personally that we say because we're
gonna start getting a little
like uh nitpicky and
it completely glosses over the fact that
what we're looking at is incredible
that's just the baseline here is
incredible absolutely
yeah yeah yeah they're just kind of like
what resonates the most with us what
speaks the most you know and so that's
going to be where it kind of like
goes from yeah yeah this is the most
like overwhelming
just display of of cg talent i've ever
seen just condensed into a few minutes
it's a first time watching it like my
brain just shut off
and just couldn't even process it was
just so
so much cool stuff yeah yeah halfway
through you get desensitized to how
awesome it is you're just like
all of these are amazing i can't focus
on any of them
so yeah don't don't worry guys if like
you know we're glossing over some
renders you know we we can't we
we don't have 12 hours we have a couple
hours for sure
so yeah you guys should be very proud if
you're in the top 100 and just the fact
if you even submitted guys
like i said next week there's gonna be
the full 2401 montage three and a half
hour long
so that's that's that's a feat in itself
you guys
finished you guys hit the finish line
and you made it happen so congrats to
everybody who entered this thing
um i think it's about time we hop into
it are you guys ready to do this
let's do it yeah all right i am here we
go
all right it works yes
okay so we're gonna go through the top
hundred renders
all right and we're gonna choose 75
renders i'm in davinci right now you
guys don't see my timeline
but basically i'm going to be leveling
up
uh 75 renders from these top 100
and we're going to go through these and
we're going to just do this based off of
feeling based off of style based off of
visual composition
based off of render quality you know
based off of story
and it's going to get a bit more
nitpicky as we get towards the top
50 top 25 but for this
75 of you guys are going to be moving on
from the top 100 so uh
let's freaking do it how do you guys
feel about this render right
here i love this one i love my style
it's so unique it's clean it's fresh
yeah
so you move this one up what do you guys
think does it get the advance
oh yeah all right sweet that one goes up
dig it
the laser one oh i love it yeah the
robot
face in the cage yeah this one the
sunset
i love the color heck yeah this one gets
the level up
that little little camp
love this one too yeah this one's
sick so super sick yeah this one gets
the level up for sure
oh this one's ren's favorite i'm a
sucker
and i love that star that little solar
flare too like it's so good
yeah this one gets the power this gets
the level up for sure
and that is cool cool fireworks
i love these carrying great fireworks
yeah i like the vibe on this one what do
you guys think upper
moving on up yeah okay
cool all right
this one is moody i love it yeah
yeah you think so top 75
i don't know we're gonna have to bring
them all out yeah
it's a bit hard to see what's going on
it's a little dark yeah it's a little
dark
all right which i like the darkness but
it you know it also makes it unclear
yeah i feel like a little bit of like
that i
yeah i i for me i just don't get what's
going on this one on the other hand
oh this one that this one's one of my
favorites
i love the style of this one
yeah the jet with that that uh that line
behind it the
the what do you call the the the line in
the air the cloud line
oh shoot we're getting we're getting
some lag it looks like
on this oh no yeah
hmm i wonder if there's a better way to
do
this hmm
we gotta freeze you again clint i know i
know
one fps shoot
oh no i wonder what on stream settings
let me change
ah i should have done normal latency
here
but i don't think i can change that
while i'm streaming
oh
huh someone said the renders are leggy
but we're fine
really yeah
um maybe it's a da vinci
situation here
huh
well
yeah it's a little crunchy on my end huh
let me pull up uh
let me pull this up and see cpu is
pretty maxed
close premiere oh yeah
let's close some programs here there's a
lot going on here guys
let's see oh boy
we can close desktop center oh no
yeah what is maxing this out freaking
obs dude is crunching
that makes sense
yeah don't don't reset obs god no
okay all right let's see
maybe that helps a little bit i don't
know anyway this one goes up we know
that
that one goes up
all right i love this one i love the
color contrast between the orange and
the blue
yeah bunch of
freaking pride rock in the background
dropping bodies off of it
yeah that's beautiful absolutely
beautiful this one goes up for sure
i like the subtle use of volumetrics
yeah it's very nice
this one's cool it's base it's very much
so inspired by the video game limbo
yeah very unique art style
yeah use of silhouettes and grayscale
i dig this one i dig this one a lot also
should we also point out the like
reestablish the rules real quick i mean
most people
uh watching right now probably you know
submitted something so they're already
familiar but
you want to like restate what the rules
were clint yeah so basically
um the idea is that you were you guys
were given a character
and you can't touch the
the like the walk cycle essentially the
only thing you can move are the hands
so in this case the character or this
this uh
dario touch the hands and
move them up to this ball here and
there's also a spherical element that
was provided
that you guys can see maintained through
a lot of these renders so you can see
this little spherical element here you
can see the character walking and you
can't
you can't touch the camera in relation
to the character so the character has to
stay in the same spot
and the spherical element needs to be
maintained so
yeah let me um someone actually had a
good idea they said just turn off the uh
turn off the webcams potentially that
way we can just actually look at the
renders
so let me see
real quick um
what if you also reduce the uh playback
resolution
in davinci can you do that you know like
set to half rez or whatever i don't know
because davinci's taken 30 of computer
juice
and so is so is obs
and the other i don't know 40 is the
rest of my computer i suppose
so let me see i just i know that your
guys's video is tied to your audio so
i'm trying to no i can i can turn off my
webcam are you ready
boom wait hold on
let me no then it's just like
peter's a skype now
[Laughter]
dang it's like i feel like it's laggy
even
with the video paused
i mean what do you have running on
chrome chrome is a huge uh
ram hog and cpu hog let me close as much
as i can
is da vinci running on your cpu or gpu
um i don't know how to even check that
hmm
yeah um maybe i can close
the chat or not the chat but at least
now but i need to see the stream
i mean you can pull the stream up on
your phone that's what i'm doing
oh yeah yeah thanks for your patience
guys
sorry about the technical difficulties
i'll pull the stream up on my phone be a
stream without some technical
difficulties
yeah but it's like the stream stats you
know what i mean you should be able to
see the stream
stats uh and i don't
quite give me two seconds give me two
seconds here
so also uh in davinci go to playback
then go to timeline proxy mode and set
to half resolution
okay playback uh what is it
timeline proxy mode half resolution yes
please
amazing also davinci is default set to
cpu but you can set it to
nvidia yes
oh wait hold on so you're yeah how do i
do that if you go to your settings go to
memory and gpu
and change your gpu configuration to uh
memory and gpu which settings here
uh which setting system settings well
these are project settings yeah
uh preferences preferences
memory memory
system memory let's see gpu i think it's
using gpu
gpus on yeah okay
dang okay well let's give this a shot
um and see how this goes i'm still
getting the error on youtube's end but
like
let's keep moving this one goes up right
we like this one
yeah oh yeah bam
oh yeah this one
watch the dude transform yeah
i wonder how they did that turns into a
werewolf yeah it's freaking sick
i wonder if it's just like a body and
then just like extruding some hairs
yeah i think it's a shape although i
guess he doesn't have that legs and
stuff
and then okay and then hair's going up
do you think this one goes up definitely
yeah we're we're still getting lag in
this like every video is like a lagged
version of it
basically oh somebody's saying that
relates you using the part is on your
system say again peter
somebody's saying two things one that
the more overlays you use
uh the harder it is on your system and
the second one i already forgot
okay hmm what if you just use the full
screen
the video that we're watching is the
only thing yeah
yeah i can try that um
overlays yeah let's let's give it a shot
um let me see if i can turn you guys
this video off without your audio going
down
can you guys give me levels yeah okay
check check so that's connected
to the sound bone and the sound bone is
connected to the
all right let me figure this out y'all
we're gonna get this going
um okay okay
was that my spider-man model no
so i'm trying to figure out how to add
hmm do you not just make it so that the
what we're seeing currently your screen
share is just what
is streamed
i could do that
but i need your guys's audio and your
audio is connected to your
video so i guess i just need one
person's video is all i need
let me see let me turn off
okay one thing clint yeah chad is going
nuts right now
time timeline settings
where is it oh here we go
screw it 1280 son
no it doesn't scale great
um let's give that a shot and see
if that works
okay next time i won't do low latency
when i'm adding a million things
[Music]
oh that's looking better
we like this one right this one can go
up
yeah i dig this one yeah no audio my
goodness
bear with me
yeah video is a little better a little
better okay still laggy
test test test
can you guys give me some levels hey
test test audio is fine
yeah audio's fine next five minutes
you say ian i just gave him levels
okay cool talking about coffee
[Music]
hmm yeah this one needs to oh man the
chat's moving too quick obviously
uh obvious needs to stream from davinci
not your desktop
okay okay let me try something
[Music]
a display capture or a media source
let's try media yeah i'll try media
source
no no that's like a video
okay so somebody's saying obs delete
desktop capture
create window capture select davinci
window capture bam
oh that's a peter and this is the best
tech support ever it's so fast
get out of here monitor
window capture okay
did somebody just pay five bucks so that
they could give tech support
i think so that's amazing shout outs
what did they say it was only up for
like half a second
all right y'all you're seeing some live
live
stream tech in here this is what goes
into
into this live stream it's a lot
so let's see this might work a lot
better
okay anti-original has a good suggestion
if this doesn't work
okay i'm all ears dude
they're saying create a new scene in obs
with only resolve in it and enable
desktop audio recording in the audio tab
so that way audio would work without
showing the webcam okay
let's see like pin that definitely pin
that and uh
got it
how are we feeling on this one top 75
i dig it oh wait are we yeah yeah i like
this one cool
i like the little uh of the bones
i love this one love this one yeah
clint it looks great yeah this one goes
up
oh excellent the stream hey it's working
it's working it's working this one i
love
this one's so good this is one of
one of my favorites so i actually
originally thought that
this robot had like a tail like a huge
slug tail but i think he's actually just
holding a slug he's like
oh interesting yeah i don't i don't know
like this one's super sick definitely
goes up for me i just don't know yeah i
don't know where the slug tail comes in
yeah but there's like the tail
he's like he's holding it under his arm
you know like
off to the side maybe god's lagging
again
oh no okay okay
okay we got this someone said right
click
uh generate optimized media
there is a nuclear option what is the
nuclear option
ending the stream and do it turning off
the low latency mode
that is pretty darn nuclear how would
that even work
i don't know you just post a link to the
new stream in the old stream
i said well it would still be the same
stream link through youtube right you're
just restarting
obs would that kill this no it's not obs
thing it's a
youtube thing so i'd have to end the
stream switch to
normal latency and then go back
everyone say do it restart it come back
redo it
oh man is that gonna fix it you think
i don't know i've never done that before
i've never chopped it up into two things
before
i'll never know and though all the links
that we shared online won't work anymore
i know
okay hold on um what peter what was that
one last option that you said
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
um what was it oh it was to create a new
obs
scene without any of our webcams using
desktop audio capture to capture what
you're getting from skype
of all of us as opposed to piping in the
webcams and the audio oh man that's a
lot
that's a lot everyone's saying restart
it restart the stream
nougat dang
uh boy that's a
i mean i had a really good suggestion
they said take a deep breath
i could use that i mean that's that's
always a good suggestion
oh yeah i'll get a sip of water too
there you go ian how's the weather up
there in uh washington
pretty pretty good pretty good we had a
couple days of 80
which was nice and now we're back down
to like oh 60s for the next
however many weeks we keep getting that
where it's like
middle summer like i think we touched 90
degrees and it goes back down like 50
60 degrees for a couple weeks uh you
guys got good summers up there
uh in theory although lately they've
been all smoky you know
right down there
all right so if i can just get your
guys's audio
i think that would check
helpful scheduled stream can restart
scheduled stream can restart so if i
stop the stream and
restart it it'll pick back up i've never
done that before
man what what unit of currency is that
i'm not sure whoa
that's wild uh let's see restart will
not fix it it's an
upload speed issue but a hardware
overload oh it's not an
upload speed issue but a hardware
overload
um have you tried
nixon or webcams yeah but i need but
your audio is attached to
the webcam streaming but you can do an
audi
a desktop audio capture of your skype
okay let's try this bear with me all
thank you for hanging in i appreciate
everybody's time
all right so i'm gonna get rid
of our heads and you guys aren't gonna
be able to hear
our boys for a minute you'll just be
able to hear me
so they can't hear you now so we're
we're gonna add let's see
screw it i'm gonna show you guys how
confusing this is bam look
at look how crazy this is right here
inception all right so here's what i
need to do this is
they see all the craziness that's going
down right here
yeah bam okay
so
here we go we want to
got rid of your guys's heads we're gonna
right click up in here we're gonna add a
desktop
what is it a desktop audio source or an
audio output which one
that's a thing where is that
audio
shoot
i need to full screen this crap i can't
see anything
thank you all thank you for bearing with
us trying to fix this lag situation so
you guys can freaking see what the heck
is going on thank you for hanging in
there with us
now
they still can't hear you yeah yeah
exactly
um yes it does
i'm gonna bring you guys back in here
let's see
all right you guys are back in i'm
bringing your videos back in
[Music]
i just need your guys audio and not your
video
check well
hello bandwidth highest no
audio only no lowest lowest bandwidth
how about that
is obis encoding on your gpu i have no
idea
that was one suggestion
to make it better yeah and
another common suggestion is use nv enc
encoding
in obs but i don't think it's an
encoding actually it might be an
encoding issue because
that takes hardware under
settings output no bs all right hold on
[Applause]
i got this one fire to put out here let
me see your guys's heads are gone
um it's just so dang tiny
let's see ren let's reset ren
screw it i'm gonna do audio only reset
i'll just do audio only
i think it'll just be better that way
okay so you guys are just audio only
right now
and cool
let's try this again
all right
so we get levels from y'all you guys can
we hear you hey
check all right hey all right so you
guys
we got audio levels um
and now we're trying to play this video
and it's doing its best here
um looks like it's playing to me cool
cool i'm just terrified to play it for
too long
oh yeah so i love this one this one's
great yeah this one goes up for me
super dope little guys in the audience
okay
so but we're back to like we're all
we're all live right now right like
we are live yeah we're we've been live
yeah everyone can hear you
no i'm learning your phrase like we're
no longer troubleshooting we're back to
reviewing
we are back to reviewing for the next 10
seconds
yes um how do you guys feel about this
one this shot
i love this one i it looks like it looks
real to me it looks like an actual like
shot you know i love the foreground
elements i love the silhouette i love
the
the light rays behind the the elephant
yeah yeah okay elephant's like
hey i'll get you guys in here this one
oh yeah i love this one go back wait
yeah i got you i got you i got you
i love this one so much i love that
little orb that he's pulling i love the
way the sand is kicking up
under water there and of course that
fish
is such a cool looking fish yeah i love
the fish this one was good
and then the fish appeared and it's like
yeah this one's great the first time i
saw this i didn't see the fish until
like the last moment so it was like this
shot evolves
over the few seconds yeah it's that
reveal it's all about that reveal it's
like super nice
yeah i'll move this one up
this one people are saying this is a lot
better
good great oh i
love this one yeah this one's sick it
makes me feel warm and fuzzy
it's just like it's like super nice i
like the vibes
i like the colors um the render quality
is really really good i'm digging this
one a lot oh wait
yo this one's been updated it has been
it has been yes no more floating burns
nope no more floating birds
all right this one goes up for sure yeah
i love this one
it reminds me of the new pixar movie
luca
oh yeah which is very good by the way
so it looks like we're still getting lag
guys um i think
it's like it's good for a second and
then it goes back to just being laggy
um maybe just look at each one
individually
at least this first round kind of like
just let it build up a buffer and
we talk about each one for a sec also i
think something to note is that we're
like
pausing and going back and skipping
around so that might look like lag
to the audience no i'm looking at the
the stream and it's definitely
frozen like i'm looking at it now and
it's just completely frozen
yeah um
so the stream's bitrate is saying is
lower than the recommended
just open this thing let's see yeah
yeah it's we're on a lower bit rate is
what it's
saying stream status is good um
yeah part of me which i wish i could
just redo this with normal latency
what do you guys think you think we
should just
reset this thing and like reboot it and
have everyone come back how confident
are you that
changing that latency setting will fix
this
um it is like we're basically at us
crawling right now we're at a snail's
pace and i think that if
it's an option but like peter said it is
a nuclear option
so
yeah trying to figure that out
i mean if you think it'll legit fix it
okay have you tried putting on the gpu
in
obs no i should
yeah yes h264 encode
okay where do where do i go under
settings
file uh no like on the on the right
under like the streaming buttons
settings yes
yeah and then uh just under output
change the encoder to
indunk the uh
streaming encoder i can't
mess with it because i think i'm
streaming oh no
you can you cut the stream and then
restart it with an obs
while still keeping the youtube link
i think so i'm gonna i'm gonna freaking
try it i'm just gonna try it
um if the stream goes down we'll be back
there'll be a new link it'll be on the
discord i'll
tweet it out and if it goes down i will
switch to normal latency
and let's let's give it a shot all right
i'm gonna stop streaming
see ya see you in two seconds don't go
anywhere
what happens to see if we get back cool
okay i think we're back
[Music]
are we back hello hello yes
still waiting for me to update on my
all right we're back in pixelated the
stream
oh wait no no no that's my settings for
some reason normie
okay we're back cool
how do you guys feel about this render
yeah i love it yeah i love it too
yeah let's move it up oh it's buttery
again
oh yeah now it's working well hopefully
let me give it a minute
give it a minute this one's gorgeous
yeah yeah this one's cool i don't get it
though i don't exactly know what's
going on also i just realized your
name's on that giant experience
it is punisher corp i love the character
animation for that little robot
it's so expressive yeah this one get
this one goes up for sure
ooh the big army
i like this i like the color contrast
it's cool
it's cool but what do you think should
we pass on it for top 75
don't know i yeah i don't know i i would
guess on this one
we gotta say like not pass one at every
four
i feel like we're either above or below
hey i'm gonna get you guys hey on
playback let me get some playback here
uh playback
quality 1080.
let's give it a shot making it better
hold on that pop
yeah this one's cool i i like the colors
and the
design like the graphic design element
to this yeah
as far as animation and story i don't
find it
too compelling yeah agreed i think
like the art direction here i think is
really cool but it
it it just is limited to that you know i
don't really
it's just a bunch of dudes that were
duplicated instanced out and are all
just kind of walking
yeah we do need to choose 75 of the 100
so i'm down
if we think that to move on i'm down and
move on
already in the top four percent yeah
yeah
this one i like a lot yeah i like the
idea of just dude pulling a boat
walking on water freaking sauron's eye
in the background
and what's going on underneath the water
surface also just look at that substrate
going on when the lightning hits it and
all that like yeah those dudes below the
water
yeah it's people it's people
that's so cool yeah
it's freaking the volumetric clouds in
the background damn
yeah it just looks like a painting i
love this one i love the clouds yeah i
look like a classic painting
yeah that goes up that goes up for sure
um
how do you feel about this guy here this
just feels calm
i think calm relaxing vietnamese rice
field
looks like yeah i dig the uh
like the visual composition uh i like
the silhouette i think it's placed
nicely so
i think this one should go up yeah cool
yeah
this one's sweet i don't know what's
burning in the background but like some
sort of
planetary uh fiery wipe
i think the moon just blew up something
like that yeah
so this one this one is playing a little
bit laggy on my end
damn the background environments in this
one are
are really cool so much detail on the
horizon
is this a dark souls type deal yeah it's
dark souls that's like the
little fire right here and then this is
i think the
starting level of dark souls but i think
this one's beautiful and
should definitely go up yeah definitely
um so playback on that one was laggy
uh but this one is playing smooth for me
so yeah this one i like too but having
literally just seen
another one that was similar i don't
know what he's dragging though it's a
giant skull so i guess he just finished
a monster hunt
it's kind of good it's a monster
i like this one i think this one is very
like the lighting is great
i agree ian
i like the purple flowers yeah let's
bring it up heck yeah
yeah oh man i love this one oh yeah
i'm the dude taking a crap in the back
yeah
yeah yeah this one goes up it's very
unique tiles
it really makes it uh look like you know
there's motion going on and of course
obviously the freaking
foam simulation going on i don't know
how they would have done that
that has a shaving cream viscosity yeah
yeah this one this one's great i like so
much going on
i love the story on this the vibes yeah
oh the puck is popping appeared
yeah this one goes up yeah
i love this one too i love the
brightness of it
top 75 trees
also i love everyone's creative take on
twisting
what the that sphere in the background
is for instance this one that sphere is
an explosion so it's not actually there
on the first frame
but it is there yeah yeah it is nice
i like it let's try and let's try and
bring back the uh webcam
and see if we can we can do that
successfully
we've just not uh we've lifted all of
them
but like one out of the last like it's
so much harder being
harsh when it's like a stream
i know i know it was already felt so
hard
when we went through it the other night
and now it's just like knowing that
whoever really
like watching it's like oh man they're
all so good
like it's literally only i think two
that we've not
passed on so far yeah it's like two or
three
all right i'm just gonna real quick um
reset your guys's heads
up in here um give me half a second i'm
gonna try
i'm gonna try to reset peter oh get that
yawn out that nice big yawn
um all right i'm gonna try and get you
guys set up in here
all right everyone everyone still wants
to be mean
be mean okay yeah
well of course they want us to be mean
they enjoy that
all right ren i got your little little
red head back up in here
sweet okay let's see
give me some levels guys hey check check
one two three
hi names peter
all right hello so now uh let us know
guys hopefully this goes well moving on
do we like this one do we think it's top
75 i like this one
i love the i love the the particles i
love the
depth of field i love the detail i love
the the dedication to just the orange
color palette and the glow i don't know
smoke
yeah this one goes up for me
it feels like a bunch of like stock
assets kind of to me that were like put
together really well
i feel i love this one
yeah this one's great so creative i like
a lot yeah this
just nails the stop-motion look this
goes up and i have that exact
time-lapse of stop-motion so yeah we'll
we'll touch on we'll touch on all these
ones that are getting leveled up in
detail as
as we get a little further into it but
right now we have
roughly let me see how much we have
we've we've passed on two
and we're about 25
percent all right so we
got a little more
sorry this one has to go up and we
haven't looked at that yet yeah this
one's great
this one's amazing yeah this goes up
i love eyeball one it's unique i don't
know if i need to see it go up
it's unique yeah i don't know how do you
guys feel i love this one
i like it i would put it up all right it
goes up it's definitely top 75.
i love the colors this is top 75 for
sure
oh my god there's also stuff going on in
the background yeah it's like a little
operation
i playing katamari oh is that cotton
yeah oh
[Music]
so sick this goes up yeah great muppet
caper
i haven't thought of moving forever
this one's creepy as hell oh i love how
it's all the little uh
i guess those are rats i initially
thought they were beetles but you only
really see the
they're curved back yeah as they just
be out of the way i dig it i think it
should go up i recently noticed that the
the rat in the background is actually
moving it's just
huge so it's moving really slowly i
think he is moving
too slowly like detrimentally slowly for
the shot you know it's like he needs a
little bit more
more motion in mind he's just like two
key frames yeah it's too slow
it's too slow i hear you um what do you
think should we pass on it or move it up
move it up yeah okay there's so much
going on there's a good one
the atmospherics and this one are nice
yeah this one that i just have no idea
what's going on
i love the mud low tides it's like a
little fluid sim or something on the
feet yeah it's beautiful this one's
beautiful it is this one's running a
little chuggy for me i think it's a 4k
one
um but this is beautiful i i think this
should definitely go up this is top 75
for me for sure
sure yeah i love how
people have been doing like cloth sims
on their characters
there's some really good cloth things
going on
this one uh we're looking at the snowy
orange dude this one's well done it's a
little plain
yeah it's plain in my opinion in the
composition
but it i feel like it could use a little
bit more detail
yeah are the clouds strobing in the
background yeah they're popping
they're like popping in there like
you're gonna go minimal you gotta like
really dial in the stuff you do have
yeah for sure
i agree like this one would have been
better had there been
some things connecting the background to
the foreground a little bit more
to kind of more show off the parallax
personally i i'd pass on this one yeah
due to that it's just it's a plane you
know it's a plane
and it makes it plain
so these 4k ones are a little chunky but
this looks cool
yeah yeah this one feels pretty unique
to me
it's he's like a little 2d cutout
what do you guys think should we pass or
you think uh good for 75. i like it but
i'd pass
yeah yeah i feel the same it's
definitely a sweet render
but again it's it's difficult to
understand like the story of this one
i guess it's you know scanline guy
escaped his machine
oh yeah yeah he's taking that arcade
taking the arcade with him
like it has story to it i maybe this is
top 75 it has story
and it's like it's well done
well done i like the chromatic
aberration going on it's like just
subtle enough yeah
i'll move it up
this one i love yeah
so anything titanfall related is
automatically really cool in my book
but at the same time it lacks
originality in the sense that like it
is a reference you know it's it's uh
you know it's referencing a pop culture
thing a video game
and to me when we're
up to these top picks and whatnot
it it kind of it's it's slightly
detrimental in terms of the originality
but
i think it's absolutely top 75 i i agree
but
it is so well done like the environment
work yes so gorgeous it looks straight
out of the background
yeah amazing i'm gonna move this up this
is good
oh absolutely
this one i like but i have no idea
what's going on it's
it's like almost too abstract dang this
one's laggy too i'm gonna switch back to
uh
12 1280 here it's definitely
sweet it's but yeah i'm i'm having like
i don't immediately know what's going on
and
can connect on an emotional level with
it like i can a lot of the other ones
i guess yeah dribbling some stuff on him
the fluid sim is sweet
yeah i love how the light is catching it
let me try pre-rendering these real
quick um
that's a good idea
how you guys doing you guys hanging in
there
i'm doing all right
yeah you can do your thing i've been
drinking too much coffee
let's um yeah go for it all right just
pause pause the stream everyone sorry uh
um
a parting thought for the audience isn't
lasagna just
spaghetti flavored cake
wait what just say that and leave
he just left
oh ian how are you doing man dude i'm
doing good have you have you heard of
corridor digital
they're this youtube channel i have yes
indeed they just
featured me in one of their videos and i
haven't had a chance to watch it
dude that's awesome i have not had a
chance to watch it either but
you did a little vfx arts react thing
right
yeah they all like sit on the couch and
they like react to stuff
that's awesome and you did did you talk
about dynamo
yeah yeah dude so good man freaking
insane that so it took you three years
to do
try to figure how to do the next one uh
faster which has been which has been fun
still keeping it 20 minutes ish
no no i mean i love the idea of doing
like a two-minute
one too just because it's the internet
you know you can do you can do whatever
but uh and the next one like feature
length i don't know i always think
that's
great about the internet is you can make
them whatever length you want
absolutely yeah do you think you'd ever
do a feature length thing
i'd i'd love to just every time i've
ever played with anything
you know in the feature realm it takes
so long that i'm
totally scared for sure yeah for sure i
feel like
especially too if it's in your style
where it's like just crazy vfx world
it would be oh man that would take so
long my goodness
but i'm really looking into some really
cool practical locations so i can do
like
augmentation instead of like having to
generate the whole thing oh is this a
little blue bar at the bottom like the
the pre-render
yes oh so we just have to like kill time
for like
two more minutes oh no we'll be good
once friend's back we can hop right into
it
oh can render as it plays back yeah yeah
yeah like and we're we're gonna
we're not gonna like watch through it
back to back like we're gonna talk about
it a little bit and stuff so we
should've done this forever ago
hopefully this works yeah um i really
appreciate you guys
bearing with me on this stream there's a
lot of uh i know there's a lot of
technical difficulties
uh but we're gonna get through it i
appreciate you guys um
lessons learned for sure lots of lessons
learned
are you doing that going great man yeah
you're killing it on the fly
trying to man uh welcome back it's the
nature of having the cno be live
absolutely hey ren did everything come
out okay
[Laughter]
for those of you who don't know i'm
literally at a house right now
uh with a whole bunch of other people
there are literally 30 people staying at
this house
most of them are in their early 20s and
they they're already starting to party
and i'm just
out here chilling i have a really cool
backdrop but this is great i'm
i'm excited heck yeah let's finish this
up let's get this top 75 going we have
yeah we've always done three
we need to start passing guys
all right this goes up
davinch all right can you just like
okay here's another quick suggestion is
there a way to
label color label any of these so you
don't have to change their track at all
which might mess with the pre-rendering
i don't it doesn't look like it messes
with the wrench yeah it's fine okay yeah
that's good great
hello oh man dude foot man
is it just a start that's a stargate
and uh what looks like a a crystal from
zelda
or an ethereum crystal but i could i
could pass
yeah it's sweet it made me giggle but
that's as much as it's doing for me rip
this one i like i love this one
i think it's unique um and i
i hadn't seen any other render in all of
these
this whole contest like this yeah this i
love
i love the way it i forget the name of
it where you have like the spiral
that kind of just keeps going and going
like a vanishing point thing
like a mobius kind of like a mobius
mandelbrot maybe is the name of it i
can't think of the name but it's it's
got like that
you know that corkscrew going off into
the distance
i dig it you guys think uh what do you
think
yeah let's bring it up okay yeah yep
yeah that's right we're at a really good
view going on right here
starting with this one i love this one a
lot this one
evokes an immediate emotional response
yeah there's something so unnerving
about all those little characters just
kind of like
being all weird and jumping up on them
and and it feels claustrophobic
yeah this one's sick this one goes up
for me for sure
easy yeah the sim is insane
i love this one i mean look i'm wearing
a green screen
shirt right now like i'm a sucker for
green screen
this one's sick yeah way to go way to
freaking like
take the prompt and like flip it on his
head and do something cool with it like
and it's yeah it's still got that that
that
orb yeah it's got the sphere foreground
i haven't really seen many foreground
orbs
yeah that one goes up i have that ladder
right over there really
there's so many little details in this
one i love the mocap that is directing
yeah yeah the little like mocap screen
and like the director the mocap director
bones
yeah this one we'll definitely be
talking more about later definitely
god dang this one is also great i love
this one
goodness like it's not just black and
white it's it's like there's so much
tonality within all of the black and
white
of course yeah
this one is a plus a plus
it does look like uh cotton balls oh
yeah this one
this one's sick render quality is really
nice yeah i dig this one
good good use of the prompt here with
the sphere
yeah and also he's pushing against
something rather than pulling you know
yeah i dig it
it's still passed though you still pass
uh you know what i
i'm also going to pass on it too i dig
it but
i don't know it's maybe it's the color
palette isn't rich enough for me
i mean hey if it's a pass it's a pass
you know like all that matters is the
top five you know what i'm saying
that's all yeah yeah okay all right mdk
i love you
love this one yeah i just want to hang
out
yeah like there's there's a so here's
here's
now that i'm actually looking at this
again i'm i'm a little confused by the
perspective we have this ship in the
foreground shooting directly sideways to
a planet
in the distance so is the ship the size
of the planet or is the planet the size
of a ship
yeah it's just going into the distance
yeah but like the laser doesn't have a
vanishing point on it you know
i don't know i'm being super nitpicky
like needlessly
it's diffusing as it as it goes you know
this one's sick this the colors on this
guys are
freaking great this is like vibrant city
and it's my favorite
i like how the grass changes color yeah
this is what
outside lands felt like a couple years
ago when i was just high out of my mind
and they lit up all the trees with
lights
this one's this wasn't up you guys you
think
definitely cool
see this one's cool they they added i
like the addition
of all of the the the
it's not dust the snow the drift the air
drift the wind that you see yeah
uh snow drift and of course the extra
animation
i don't know if that's like mocap
animation or
mixamo i'm going on mixamo.com right now
don't do it peter i'm doing it what do
you guys think top 75
i i would say no though i do like it
i'll pass on it
my favorite part about it honestly is
the death star the death star looks very
nice
good job it looks really nice dynamics
are good but i freaking dig it again it
goes back to the uh
it's i mean i don't know i feel like
star wars anything directly referencing
it is uh
overplayed it is a maximum animation
i love it i love it was it laughing did
you have been laughing
yeah so this one though the uh
i'm getting some real horizon zero dawn
vibes from this and i love that game
and it's not it's not not a direct
reference like i was literally just
saying a moment ago but
i got the vibes and i like the implied
story here that he's dragging a
parachute you can see like a crashed
spaceship in the background it's pretty
sweet
i love that crash spacecraft i love the
the clouds kind of forming the the
circle element
with the flare going right to the middle
like that's that's really cool
yeah this is an up this is for sure
enough yeah so i think
i've been really appreciating the use of
negative space for that sphere instead
of actually having
a tangible sphere same idea
because we're about halfway through um
we if we love it let's just say up
because we're gonna come back to it
we're gonna talk about it later when we
see it again
so if we if we love it let's just let's
just say all agree like yep move it up
if we feel like should be a pass then
maybe we can touch on y
and then we'll get into the 75 and the
50 from there does that sound good
so if you love it we shouldn't talk
about it yeah because we're going to
talk about it later only go into detail
if we don't like it okay
interesting
is this like the background blobs baby
oh well is it he's kidnapping the baby
it's like the rona it's the rhony
i think oh that's what it is yeah
uh i could probably pass on this one
it's good it's well rendered but
yeah the music i was saying this one we
talked about last time but i just kept
getting uh
wait wait go back to a clint it's the uh
mike wazowski yes there's ink
good soft body there that's good
this is incredible 100 yes 100
100
peanut man burger man definitely
definitely we'll see you later see if a
bottle cap has
i don't maybe bottle cap and cardboard
hat
okay this one i don't get what's going
on in this one uh
it's it's pretty i love the forest in
the background but i just
i don't get it you know yeah it's well
done it's just a little
like random i guess
is that a bell i don't know not sure
uh looks like hot dogs on a train in the
background
kind of oh hot dog train gets me
gets me back in
i could probably pass on this one it's
great like i said
it's your top hundred it's freaking top
notch
i love the color palette of this one i
do too but
i think the last colorful one was better
i don't know yeah this one i'm not
particularly a fan of the color palette
to be honest
uh i almost feel like the vibrance is
too high or something
like i love that
maxing out that saturation yeah
that being said i love the lighting and
the colors but besides that it doesn't
really draw me in very much
yeah i've got to pass on it
i like this one a lot i don't get it but
i
i don't know this one i think deserves
to move on mainly just because i love
anytime
someone can mess with the rules and like
reinterpret it and push the boundaries
of what the rules mean
i dig and uh having like a person on a
treadmill
i mean i'm just gonna say yes for now i
don't know i think i think so yeah i
think this one's sweet i have absolutely
no idea
what's i mean i guess it's just a person
powering an entire factory
and there's like a meat grinder in the
back or something right
all that meat doesn't notice the meat
it's like i think it's coffee beans
there's little coffee beans right up in
here no that's
he's grinding up people oh boy it gets
the up
it's a good one this one i dig a lot
this one's very uh painterly i'm just
gonna say yes for now
incredible yeah oh yeah incredible
yes i love it lucas
shout outs good stuff yeah this is this
isn't up
i love it
i like this lighting yeah i like it too
it's like it's it's such clean
composition too
uh if it's yeah yeah yeah i'll put it up
yeah i'll put it up
i'll put it up
oh my god yes yep this is probably my
least
favorite of all the 100 what are you
crazy
yeah i'm joking this one's a yes this is
so good
yeah 100 we'll see you later
i could pass on this one i could pass
it's good
i love the vibes great vibe same
it's just but it's like i could pass and
i don't know it's uh
feels a little simple shout out to mark
good stuff man i enjoy the render
great composition yeah this one's sweet
i like it volumetrics
a lot of great layers yeah i'll put it
up
yeah in the light rays
i like the vibes of this one yeah same
this isn't up come on the top 75 for
sure yeah this is
this is going up and ian's in that one
you guys want to say ian isn't that you
there
but i'm like working in a little shop
hold on let me see
you're like oh that was not much of a
punch zoom there um
so the bottom you you are
down here by these plants is that you i
think that's me and also that's the same
model of me to the
to the left there over here in the shop
yeah and then
this is sam from rococo yeah that's sam
lazarus
that's awesome all right that's enough
for sure
uh
moving on
well well this is so overstimulating
i mean it's amazing there's a lot going
on yeah i feel like it's almost too much
it's like it lacks focus
i disagree like it's
i think this is great
oh the swarm of flies around the garbage
and the like
oh yeah you're right the wind on the
garbage when the car goes by too
there's a lot going on this is top 75.
at least
yeah bump it all right bumped
oh caves rd
my boy i love this one yeah i love the
color
so much and i love that he just like
spawns out of the gas
emitting out of the ground the fireflies
particle system yeah that's 100
it's also just gorgeous lighting yeah
it's gorgeous lighting absolutely like i
could use a still frame at the very
the very first frame of that i could
keep is like a wallpaper he's in uh
unreal engine
as well nice this is unreal yeah it was
unreal
what
this one i love a lot it's a good story
yeah yeah there's a story going on
definitely getting some neo breaking out
of the matrix vibes here i'll put that
up
that goes up
oh oh ops
we'll come back we'll see you later
what's the name of that town uh purpiet
outside of the
in the ukraine uh chernobyl you know
right he's definitely got some trouble
vibes on this
this kid just wants to find his parents
oh it's really good
um well they know they're in the
background look to your left
what where no there's just somebody
under an umbrella
oh no that's a flesh-eating marauder
what what where from the right yellow
brother oh oh oh oh somebody
the chromatic aberration is
[Music]
i like this one the color palette
is not for me
but it's very it's like it's like
intentionally muted
i'm not gonna lie i like it a lot but at
the same time it doesn't speak to me so
i could have it yeah i'm down to pass on
it it's great
i dig it little pass the environment
work is very good
great i like this one i like those
little lights on the string
depth of field is done right here i feel
yeah i think this is good it's unique
lit well fun yeah
yeah is it getting his own hand in a
pencil sharpener no there i think
there's a pencil in there it's hilarious
he's sharpening his hand
[Laughter]
oh i love the giant creature in this one
i just wish i knew what the [ __ ] was
going on
i mean i guess it's like a titan uh
attack on titan thing right
dude he blew a hole through this wall
that's exactly oh that's the wall from
attack on like that's what happened
10 seconds before this oh
that's dope yeah let's bring it up
yeah yeah i see yes
[Laughter]
yeah this one is the best this is my
fiancee's favorite one
it just makes me giggle i love it
this is this gets up it's so perfect
it's good the world is crazy but i think
i could
pass on this one personally
yeah i mean it's got some really nice
high detail going on
both in the foreground and the
background yeah
the design is gorgeous yeah that
background is
amazing should we put it up then
it's a yes from me yeah yeah we are
doing 3v1
god damn 100
it feels intense i can feel it's intense
we'll come back to that
i like this one a lot this is so funny
so they're going for like the studio
ghibli vibe here right
that being said i wonder like are these
cutouts for movies
being placed in here or are these
originals i i don't
know that's another thing that is kind
of hard to judge is like
how far does the asset creation go are
they just pulling from a library and
placing stuff in
versus creating the assets from scratch
who knows
uh it's hard to kind of
judge something because obviously the
more creative asset creation
that goes into something the richer and
more uh novel it is
versus kit bashing i want to assume they
they drew all of this
yeah yeah cause the the guy pulling the
car that's definitely not from a ghibli
movie
and the uh the painted look like
projected on the geometry is so
it's so amazing i think you should go up
but there's little crabs
there's crabs on the street yeah oh my
god that's awesome yeah these little
guys
all right ian you love the crabs
crab i laughed out like okay i laughed
out loud when
uh she looked out the window and saw
that crab with the sword that was like
my favorite part of the whole thing
i love the use of silhouettes here it's
like this is like an artfully done depth
mat
yeah i'm down on this but i could
i could probably pass on this one yeah
i could too yeah you know it's gorgeous
but it doesn't
stand out i don't know it it stands out
but at the same time i can pass
it's like it feels rich
and it feels intentional uh
oliver gorgeous though shout outs to
oliver
oliver i'll see ya shout out on the next
one
[Laughter]
it's good but i could probably pass on
this one too i could pass on it i don't
know nothing's really jumping out to me
as
like noteworthy it's it's a cool you
know graveyard scene
it's lit well enough i don't know and i
i can't put my finger on what's not
speaking to me about this
yeah i love the the low mist mixed in
there with the weeds but
uh sure i think it had like some more
interesting
lighting going on i think something i
really that speaks to me in these
renders is having a little
like a tiny little confusing element
it's like oh wait what's going on here
and then your brain you figure out the
story you're like oh that's what's
happening and then you feel
it's like rewarding for watching the
render because you kind of like figure
out the story
and i feel like in the ones where there
isn't much of a story it's just it's
looking at a very pretty painting
but you know also i'm also coming to
realize that i
i think another thing that kind of
pushes me away from
liking something like this is that you
know they're not really taking advantage
of the actual mocap
context you know like this person is
just like leaning really far forward
holding a lamp
and it doesn't really seem justified you
know like he's not pulling anything he's
not pushing anything
not you know resisting motion
it's got to lean into the bat stream
yeah
yeah it's like the air is thick with bat
poo poo
you know but i'll pass on this one yeah
you guys agree yeah okay
compositionally it's nice but yes i pass
shout outs paul
i like the initial uh the punch of
contrast you know yeah it's nice
silhouettes are great
the wind is great yeah glare
the grass animation is wild
not quite sure what's going on is it
choppy that's just the way it is
that's just the way it is is that how
the song goes i don't know
i think it's just wind i could pass on
this one it's it's nice
too yeah shout outs i'll be lost i think
great environment design i'm curious
that this isn't purple
do they does kit bash 3d have a like a
stacks
pack or that the ian hubert pack
can you see any of your assets ian uh i
don't think so
not that that's you know like a factor
no i'm just curious
like i'm just trying to not you know uh
i multiple people message me worried
about that
the uh the stacks i don't know it speaks
too much ready player one for me
it's a solid vendor though bring it up
because it's like there's so many little
things going on everywhere yeah i'd
bring it up
i'll move it up it gets the it gets the
upgrade also by the way
we have just under 6 000 people in this
live stream right now
that's insane really yes what's up
everybody
that's like that is more than four times
uh the amount of max people i've ever
had like this is insane guys thank you
for joining us
shout outs um thanks to ian peter and
ren for doing this
with us going to the top hundred renders
we're whittling it down to top 75 right
now we're gonna get down to the top five
and uh
and issue some some prizes to some
winners um
yeah so thank you guys thanks for
helping in here thanks for sticking in
thanks for
seeing it past the uh the technical
difficulties we're on the
i feel it now we're doing we're doing
well
i don't know what technical difficulties
you're talking about it's been smooth
perfectly flawlessly let's keep going
sick i love the style of this one yeah
this one yeah this one's bomb
ups oops i love that the sun shines on
everyone doesn't even fit like in the
circle
it actually genuinely feels like nested
graphic design
mm-hmm um ian you get the ups
yeah yeah i feel so alive
i love this one i love this one i love
the idea that like you have these giant
floating
spheres you know i guess dropping
pesticide on the on these fields but
they there's no propulsion system for
them so you got to like tow them
but you're still using robots to do it
that was pretty i like the robot design
yeah
it's a good mobile design super dope
this gets the ups
good composition yeah
i love this one love it ups 100 percent
it's up it's chilling the more i watch
this one the more i don't like it
no sorry the previous one we'll return
this one also
yeah we'll get to it this one i like i
like this this one i like
yeah me too it has like i love the
dynamic range is incredible the
silhouettes are so cool i think the only
thing that detracts it for me is i wish
i saw some more
like texture detail it just seems like
there's a lot of
bump detail and displacement detail but
no like
texture i kind of like the ground on
everything
i feel like that's kind of the style
yeah i suppose
i'm down against the up for now
cool
this one's gorgeous
yeah the flowers growing that's a pretty
sweet system i don't know how they did
that
if that's like a c4d thing or like a
houdini thing i don't know
pretty dope just right let's bring it
i'm bring it up
all the way up
this one i love this one so much i don't
know what it is about it but it just
looks so
clean yeah so sharp it's like it's like
the mids were lifted or something
perfect
like ah or like this like it's like the
mids were lifted and the and the blacks
were like crushed down
just enough and the color correction is
perfect this definitely goes up
yeah i love how textured the grounds are
in
like so many of these yes you can feel
like you can catch it yeah
dang pretty freaking sweet so like
the fantasy element here i love this
the the little staff is a little it
feels a little glitchy it does
a little wonky on the arm movement i
love the tiptoe
uh maneuver yeah tiptoe on water feed
the puddles
yeah that's well done sorry the ripples
going out i wish that big foot did
something to the water
oh a big splash oh yeah it does kind of
space through huh
what do we think guys i really like this
one
i like it
god dang it
this one's in the thumbnail today it is
this goes up for me
easy that's like some of the best i love
the the cloth sim work
going on but we could talk about this
more later yeah that's amazing i feel
like i can
yeah spooky town
i'm gonna say no on this one i'd say
this one's an automatic pass for me i
don't know why
uh i'm down a bit i like it yeah i'm
down to pass on it um we got to get
you know we got to whittle this down you
know it's yeah
yeah it's dope but compositionally i
feel like it could be a bit more focused
as opposed to like
like here's a bunch of different things
you can look at as opposed to
here are a few things that make sense
together that you can look at
yeah shout outs to sean good stuff man i
love it
what is this i don't know
yeah i'm having a hard time
understanding this yeah i don't know
it's like what it is like i think
there's an i'm intrigued
definitely there's also like
weird light directions going on right
now you have like the giant light source
in the back but there's a shadow from
the dude on the little like
broken wall piece behind him it was like
obviously there's a spotlight coming
from behind here i don't know it's
it's it's very interesting i could pass
on this one it looks like he's dragging
a giant like
fleshy baked potato plushie baked potato
yeah it's interesting but it's hard to
understand which
gives it a pass in my book
cool simon shout outs man good stuff
dang i love the use
of the foreground element extending into
the background to give
a sense of scale yeah yeah like this
one's certainly a lot better than that
that one we looked at at the beginning
with the uh just the flat brown and the
orange jumpsuit
it's like having that that pipe going
off into the distance really helps
cement it all together
i was doing the uh or like listening to
the
developer commentary for half-life alex
and like the first map that you load
into with all those
giant pipes going off in the distance
that's why they did that
is to give you a sense of scale that's
cool watch it you guys man i'm all about
that sense of snail
sense of scale this is enough for y'all
yeah pups yeah god
um is a favorite yeah
i like it so much this is one of my
favorites 100
100 i just love the justification for
the mocap
yeah yeah yeah
oh man this one's also great
this goes up now move
this one's kind of depressing it's it's
beautiful
what do you all think i'd say oops yeah
yeah i'll bring it up yeah
oh i love that balloon it's so puffy
balloon's great
one thing that bothers me is that the
scale of the smoke sim is off it it
seems like a way bigger
smokes oh you're right yeah yeah he's
parented to the train
is that like a blown up boiler that's
weird detail
i'm like i like this one says
yeah i could pass two this one has like
it has it all
but it just doesn't do it for me
oh it's a race huh the uh
the balloon it's the country cross cup
and you can see the other racers like in
the background and his exploded
that's cool oh that's so cool
yeah this is a yes for me definitely
yeah
okay we'll move it up we'll move it up
nothing against you
nothing against you sir um
valentine
i love the detail i love the surf
surface imperfections
great the lighting is is pretty good for
uh these materials
i like the blood but i can also
the reveal of the chess piece in the
foreground that has blood is
pretty sweet that being said
i think it's a pass for me yeah
i could pass venue venue it's just i
don't know it's very sharp i love the
specular highlights on it
this one fantastic lighting
i love the background the whole like
background right yeah
beautiful the slanted building with the
steam and everything is like
sick this one gets enough for me
love the bear like the only thing my
only gripe on this one
is the background it's like the the
foreground and everything is so well
done i love the lighting is
perfect it's just that like the
background smokes him it
almost looks like they took it and they
stretched it only on one
axis or something yeah yeah
here we go i'm having a hard time
understanding what's going on in the
background you've got that really
white smokes and then the black spots
and i get they were probably trying to
just really match that cur
the the circle element so just massaging
it
but yeah i mean i i could i could pass
but i will not particularly a fan of the
composition to be honest
vlad shout outs man i like your colors a
lot
i think it's good stuff bear is great
too
this one's friggin dope this one i love
because it's
and it's another one where it's like
there's an antagonist you know
uh it's it's a it's a bit of a creative
twist on the prompt again you know where
you have
these guys that are pulling things or
pushing on things but this guy is
resisting a force
kind of like the arrows yeah this gets
the um for me just based off the fire
it's good fire too or simply pushing
through something really difficult
or persevere yeah i'm a sucker for it
gets the up yeah
getting to the last few here six wheelie
wow
this one's a good one
this is william lang land i think he's
in the chat right now um
this dude's like 14 or 15. dude's insane
he's incredible yeah this gets the up
for me
oh yeah it's gorgeous
this one is i love the colors darn
amazing
but the other
death stranding one i like to look like
just a touch better
i'm i'm kind of thrown by the scale of
this shot because it's like it looks
like the background
sorry the mountains there are way
further behind the orb that is
technically behind it
but the orb feels closer somehow i don't
know why
in the top right faster yeah
yeah it does feel a little weird it's
really i think the colors are gorgeous
the lighting is really nice however the
composition doesn't really draw
draw your eye anywhere it's got five
different spots to look at and i don't
really know where to look there's a lot
going on
no doubt it is amazing
i like it i i could pass though
okay yeah same yeah shout outs
yeah i'm a fan of that color oh i'm a
fan of that color
the colors and the density but the
composition is still like
feels really clean yeah i'm down
[Music]
um oops this looks good there's so much
going on
so many little fish yeah the bubbles the
the schools it's just like the render
quality is sick
absolutely beautiful it's thick
yeah jeez
god damn so much weather i love it i
love the light it's like
the hovercraft flies over and like
illuminates the rain
that is cool oh yeah uh
oh that is cool dude yeah in the passing
waves of yeah
is incredible this would be cool to hear
like with sound
a lot of people good sound with theirs
yeah
this gets the up for me
uh it i like it it also just looks like
ian that you did this you know this is
like straight up your style
there are some of my elements in there
yeah i think my my biggest critique of
this one would just be that the truck
isn't moving at all like relative to the
the frame it looks kind of like a
yeah it feels a little right it could be
rocking up and down a little bit or side
to side just a little bit of motion
like rattling perhaps i'll put it up
though
unless maybe is he pulling it is it on
the ground
i don't know pushing it or something oh
that's cool yeah cause there's somebody
in there i think they're push starting
it
oh that's cool yeah this gets the up
this is good
yeah and this last one is mine i'm not
done with it
yeah i'm not done with it oh this is the
first i've seen yeah
that's a pass for me definitely i'll
delete the file and i'll
delete my rim layout
thank you
another five seconds um it's a robot
that's like crashed or that's like
chilling out in this canal it's
destroyed
there's this like little machine gun up
here that
they had a little robo war going on you
know that's awesome
but yeah still working on this um hard
pass everyone in the chat agreed i'll
delete the file
bam is gone um
let's figure out what we got here let's
see we
have one two three four five six seven
eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19. we need to get rid of six
we need to get rid of six okay so i'm
gonna just like
thumb through these these thumbnails
here and we need to pick six
that need
or we can just go straight to the top
50.
that's done true moving on
let's just like this next round we're
going to be way more strict about what
makes it versus not we've now
we now have a baseline of what we've
seen we know uh the ones that elicited
the most
sort of emotional response and those are
kind of the ones that are going to
continue on
all of them are incredible all of them
have really cool color composition
tone all that stuff render settings are
all nice the simulations are all very
cool
and and well done and detailed but it's
time to be strict
yeah this is when we're just turning
dial and we're turning on our dick dial
wow all right so i need to get rid of
hold on now hold on now i tried to do a
sweet transition it didn't work
yet because i gotta i gotta undo
something real quick
uh
now maybe it'll work top 50
yes indeed is this actually the speed
the chat's going at
yeah i think so wow this is like
just seeing the matrix
pretty crazy we're on we're on top 75
right now bam all right
i'm gonna fill up my coffee you guys
want anything yeah can you grab me a
pizza
or something yeah all right i need to
redo the window capture here
how are you guys doing are you guys
doing all right
good i'm doing great i'm checking out
the chat right now
uh it is going crazy let's see let's
everyone said hi delete the window
capture and
add a window capture add the existing
window capture
oh but i got to do the freaking thing
here we go
we're going to make it work wait what
yo what's up shovel man
all right bam bam bam
i uh do i have like i just drank this
entire french press
can i can i disappear you can disappear
for 45 seconds
yeah absolutely all right
so if y'all are just joining us we made
it to the top 75
and we are gonna we're gonna review some
art here y'all
we're whittling it down it's gonna be
good
it's gonna be real good wren how you
doing man
i appreciate you i'm doing all right
taking the time i you're you're out on a
freaking like
basically like a bachelor party
i mean kinda not really but uh there's a
lot of people here
we're all like we're all vaccinated so
we're all just hanging out
chillin
oh it's just a little hangout
well hang on some friends of mine uh
rented this this airbnb
house it's massive like literally 30
people
are staying here at this house
got this incredibly nice view of this
lake
out behind me in the mountains wow i'm
really bummed i didn't bring my drones i
was told that
uh that was specifically uh banned here
oh no
but i'm regretting not doing it
yeah you kind of you probably could have
brought them and just been like hey it's
all good especially that little small
one i have
so quiet all right
so guys we i just want to jump in we've
made it
uh to the top 75
um and
it is time
down top
31 entries have to go yeah all right
yep we got to do it okay so
hang on your butts top 50 yeah your name
yeah i'm going to be strict this time
around if we end up with less than 50
great
a green a on this one i like this one
it's super cute
but i'm going to say name it don't speak
to me hard enough agreed and i'll say
nay same
sorry ian we love you right now i love
the style
also drock's thank you for your
submission it's amazing
god man i'm gonna say yes on this one i
love the sunset i love the sunset
yeah top 50 for sure i'll put that up oh
i gotta render these hold on one second
um
let's see we render all these guys
where you at bam there we go
next one not andrew price andrew pross
um it might be a little laggy guys for
this first part i'm like batch rendering
some stuff
so hang in there i love it but i i could
pass
i i if it had some more lights on those
foreground elements just
like a little bit of like more detail
showing them off it's it's like a dark
silhouette against a dark background
that is occasionally lit up
yeah like for this to work for me i want
to see
way more of the lightning going on like
make it like the middle of the most
intense lightning storm as opposed to
like a couple flashes and that's it
also on that little cable the guy's
holding it looks like it's sparking
if you used that as a light source would
have worked really well to illuminate
the subject because right now it's kind
of just falling into darkness a little
bit
or even like it's not a good silhouette
i want to see this movie
like if this were like a short film yeah
i'd want to see that so bad it's like
oil
they're they're oil rigs they're
floating oil rigs that's so cool
wow um i feel like some ground lighting
could have been nice like you could have
had um
some like under lit ground lights by the
feet that kind of
go up to the guy you know that could
have been cool to like make him pop out
a little bit but yeah i'm down to pass
but i feel like you could use better art
direction
and i love how vibrant this one is how
about that little sun
yeah right sun's awesome i love that
backpack design
yeah the vortex in the back is cool too
yeah i bring these i don't vibe too much
with the
the color scheme and the lighting the
design is a little weird
amazing but it's a pass for me i almost
feel like the blue
is doing a disservice like the blue orb
the sun
i agree it's like it's like a free tone
right now
and if they picked two tones i think it
would work better
what do you guys think i mean i i don't
know i think it's top 50 for me but i
i'm not i don't feel too strongly about
it i mean
a light yes a light yes light yes
a light note from me okay
this one i'm gonna say no uh it just
looks like
i mean the background is cool and i love
the the particle system going on for the
fireworks but i feel like that's kind of
the only thing going on for the
background
it feels like it's just a photo you know
in the background i love that the
spherical element is the fireworks
that's that is true that is true but
yeah i i passed too i'll pass yeah
it's good stuff yeah bourbon shout outs
good times caleb all right we got some
caleb up in here
it's gonna be great it's gonna be a
little laggy guys at first but it'll be
we'll be good
it's got a clean style and a really cool
creative use of a like a
portal type deal the colors and every
step is interacting with the water
i love it top 50 for me
carlos i like this one
i wish it was a little brighter but i do
i feel like the the grade on this is
is very nice and the stuff going on i
just wish i could see more of it it's
like too dark
yeah yeah it's a bit hard to read yeah a
little dark but i love
it so much um i say this one's top 50
for me but
maybe just top 50. you know
i always love subtle use of volumetrics
because the temptation when you throw a
volumetric object into your scene is to
just
crank it which looks nice but i feel
like oftentimes when you leave it subtle
it's
it feels more realistic and it pays off
i think this one should go up i like it
i like it let's bring it up
limbo
daario i i could
okay it's sick but i could pass for top
50. i could pass
i dependent on a franchise that i
haven't
that i'm not familiar with yeah it's
like they absolutely
nailed the style and the in the vibe
but again because if the reference is
too hard it it's
i don't know yeah or rather
than stand on its own a remote
the clouds that are parting as the the
guy
yeah right yeah i love little bits of
foreground like
mist too yeah this is this is a this is
a win for me i'll i'll
i'll go for this one yeah
as much as i love spider-man i have no
idea what's going on
yeah go get him spider-man yeah i'd pass
that's for sure
isn't this the scene from the movie
though when he's like on the airplane
and he's like trying to like climb along
it but
i guess now he's also getting shocked
and losing his soul out of sync
i don't know i don't know i'm gonna pass
on it
yeah i think a wing would be cool i love
it back here but
shut up it's just spiderman david yeah
good stuff good stuff
i'm having some uh some lights
flickering a little bit up here we've
got some wind so if i suddenly just
disappear
uh i love you all and say nice things
about me
oh shoot okay power what you're saying
it's probably fine it's just flickered a
couple times right so it's probably fine
so this one dennis yeah
i think i'll pass i like it i like it
it's solid but there's another one that
had
a very similar colored style to it you
know your least favorite one but friend
your least favorite out of all the
remnants no no no no
not there's a few at this color style
yeah
i don't know this one it's very pretty
but it's uh feels a bit samey
yeah like you did everything you could
do with this i think it's sick
it's the it's the unmotivated character
walking like i feel like i get what
they're going with here he's walking
into the wind but i don't see
any intensity of the wind pushing them
back you just kind of like
yeah and it needs the misty you need to
see the wind you need to visualize the
wind somehow and like you're doing it
with like the
the the little tumbleweeds
i could yeah it further like even the
barbed wire fence is kind of shaking
around
but yeah just the the lack of i think
particular or whatever
yeah i don't know it's moving up here
yeah
i can pass on it it's good i'll pass i
love it but i can pass
yeah shout outs dennis dd
great lighting i love this overcast
lighting
yeah yeah i think this one's really cool
yeah i agree top 50
oops
no question this one i like a lot yeah
this is top 50 that is
is the ground plane lower than the other
ones because he's walking
on the robot feet yeah
so it's like the actual original ground
plane
is invisible here and the one the ground
plane we're seeing is is lowered a
little bit to make room for the
robot interesting look at these
undulating like freaking
tentacle grossnesses dude look how nasty
that is
i love this it's like
yeah this one goes up that's the cool
robot design too it's definitely going
up
i like this one it's it's creative you
know it's like it's a little
paper 2d cutout show type deal i know
the audience
turns around and looks at us
i could pass yeah but i love it i love
that waterfall
anyone want to change their vote or are
we sticking to it is it a straight tie
i'm sick and he is okay it's sick i love
it
on it ends anise
good stuff very good stuff
this one just it feels so good like it
feels like a
freaking monday morning you're heading
out i work the fields
except you got elephants instead of cows
also the elephant trunk animation i
wonder if that's just
footage no that's that looks like a
model
that's just an exceptional trunk
animation
yeah i guess the up for me
this one's got the up for me for sure
yeah oh yeah just like it's got
you in the right spots yeah
oh ran your favorite yeah this is this
is a favorite of mine i like it a lot
the reveal is more detail
environmentally but the story is so good
yeah i don't want to go in the other
reveal it's all about that reveal
this this gets the ups for me on on the
story reveal
there's so few that change over the
course of the few seconds
yep yeah it evolves
what do we think that's i'm saying yes
on yeah
i love it i think it's top 15. let's
bring it up yeah i agree
good stuff i wonder if people can tell
since we know the top five i wonder if
people can tell based on how we
like select if we know if they know you
know what i mean
um this one is incredible i love it i
love the fact that he like
his little breather tube goes loose and
he grabs it and tucks it back
in i love the lighting yeah i love it
everything about this okay well that
that little tube detail
i was kind of on the fence but yeah i
want to i like that well i mean he's
just he's just like
it doesn't like break loose and he
recaptures he's just like kind of like
re-up and like
i don't know for me personally i think
this one's a little too simplistic
in in what i'm looking at i don't know
composition is really nice composition's
sick
i like it a lot also it's one of the
only ones where
he's not fighting against the wind the
wind is pushing him down
yeah that's true i'm not an up it
yeah i like a lot
such good lighting i love the
environment work in the background
all those trees and whatnot and i love
the little plants in the foreground too
we say safely say what's going on yeah i
don't know what the laser beam is going
i don't think the laser beam's doing
anything
this little robot going out this way
yeah it just seems arbitrary to me
i think he's scanning like mines
it would have been nice though power
station like
if it had uh more of like a cone style
laser that went over this foreground one
and it flashed like then it's like oh
he's scanning it but it's just like a
laser beam
off into the distance
i saw it as like that's like a little
sentry robot and he the other guy has to
like deliver the
the power station part somewhere so cool
this one gets the up i think it's great
yeah i love the character animation in
this
you guys think ian oh yeah i bring it up
cool
do you guys know what this is
referencing like is there a certain
story i don't i'm not exactly sure
i get a lot of like ancient greek vibes
from it with their gods like zeus and
stuff like that but i'm also i mean
it looks like the eye of sauron there
off to the right and the
i really love the the rendering quality
of the water
like the subsurface going on yeah looks
nice like there's so much i love i love
about this but part of me is just like
i'm good on it you know i don't know i
love the concept of like this dude
pulling a boat walking on water like it
just yeah like
what's going on and i do love the the
contrast between the red and the blue
people are saying
people are saying what dante's inferno i
think so
something like that yeah all right you
guys you guys going top 50 on this one
i say at the top 50 for me sure yeah
cool
i dig this one it's got a really chill
vibe to it
but it's too stationary in terms of uh
idea you know it's just like
nothing changes yeah i i i'll pass on it
i love i love this render so much but i
see you guys i'm down
we can move on um if from if ron
orphan
yeah sick render i love your silhouette
man good stuff
ivan with the chungus render the 4k
beefy i freaking love this
i love dark souls um i think the render
quality is
top-notch um i love
like all the low-lying fog in the
background
um i dig this one
i think i just can't read the the
character same
yeah does he have a head it would have
been nice if there was another light
source off to the light
uh off to the left that was just like
adding a bit of a rim light to the
character so that
they stood out from the dark background
just a little bit more that's like my
biggest critique yeah i feel that i feel
that i agree but i love that effect in
the background
yeah me too that's one of my favorite
parts i'm down if you guys want to pass
on this i hear you
i'm down if you i would put it up yeah
all right yeah let's put this one up and
the next one
is when we chop it back down i got a
similar vibe
this one i can pass on i don't know even
though
technically like i feel like the
lighting is better in this one it reads
better
uh i i feel like the depth is a little
too
far like i feel like the background is
way too far away
um i don't know i
i love parallax and i'm not seeing
enough of it here i dig that kind of
mystic
stonehenge thing in the back yeah oh
this is on the left
yeah i mean i i could i could pass oh
this i see you love this one
lighting's great colors i freaking love
it if you guys are passing i'm down
color grade
yeah i i love it shout outs to james
good stuff man congrats on top hundred
i dig this one a lot just cause it's so
different we're now at a miniature scale
there's not many that are out of many
interests true
and just that so looks like shaving
cream yeah no they nailed the shaving
cream
yeah it's insane both in terms of like
it's viscosity and the render
how do you think of that yeah who who's
like
the circle element will be a bottom of a
toilet
toilet this one
i'd say this one's definitely top 50 for
me oh yeah i do wish there was some
animation in the toes
yeah that would have dude if they would
have just clenched like super hard
yeah this goes up i like originality
it's fun it's a good time
jason this one dude this one's got a
story going on for sure you know
top top 50 i i think so man this one i
feel something with this
yeah all right jason we'll see you soon
uh javert jabert
this one's dope to me it does feel like
a ton of assets scattered around a scene
i could pass on this one yeah not this
one i like it yeah of course
i like all that i feel like the bokeh is
really nice i like the use of the
explosion as the circular elements
uh there's like a bit of a shock wave
coming towards the
foreground there with smoke it's
definitely a
post-apocalyptic nuclear wasteland going
on but
i'll pass on it yeah it's sick javert
sick man
thanks for joining thanks for making top
100
this one i dig a lot this one the only
motion one that i've seen that really
celebrates the article you know yeah
my only complaint about it is that like
it's just it doesn't
it doesn't read too clearly that the
foreground element is a person
uh i disagree this is sick this is like
top 50 like to me like if you see a time
lapse
no absolutely background i don't know i
don't know is it
i've always wondered what that thing is
is it like a light reflector and it's
just kind of moving
over oh you know what it might be
it might be a uh one of those umbrellas
with the light pointing inside the
umbrella
that's kind of what it looks like like a
like a foil bounce light situation yeah
yeah i can see that construction paper
trees
yeah also notice how the cup the mug
there like
yeah over the course of one frame a
couple times
yeah this is this is top 50 this goes up
yeah
we got jerome next i love
this render so much you can eat that mud
i could just have thanksgiving dinner
right there
on that rock plus those floating dudes
just like ominously floating up there
i'll fight you guys if this isn't in the
top 50. like this is
no this is topic amazing detail the uh
the tone yeah the use of color
it's like the color is is perfect here
because it's muted
but it's also still saturated enough
yeah in in relation to
itself it's perfect yeah it's tactical
color
it plays in gray which is nice because
when you're in gray you can shift to
different colors in a really smooth way
yeah i love it
the eyeball i've seen enough did you see
the sign
oh okay i've seen enough
i love that goo this one's pretty wide
it didn't have to be goo
but it is it's almost yeah it's like
it's a little too on the abstract side
in my opinion
it's like i could pass on it like it's
it's sick and i love it obviously i made
top hundred but i could pass
i i really like how the body of the the
person
is literally just the guts of an eyeball
like
the it's nerve ripped out yeah exactly
it's a great simulation yeah agreed
i think it's nasty what do y'all think
i think it's dope but i think i think
i'm
gonna pass on this round okay i'd pass
we're bringing up we need an eye socket
wait what happened are you in a nice
house
the shape the kind of the window into
the background i was wondering if that
was like an
eye socket but it could just an anime
eye a
flesh window gross
this one i could pass on i don't know it
doesn't really speak to me that hard
i like this one i love it i feel like
they could have leaned further into the
operation element of it
and again it goes for me it goes back to
the i feel like there's too much
separation between the background and
the foreground i want to see that
married a little bit more
i wonder if maybe if the operation going
on on the left back there was a little
bit closer to camera so you had a little
bit more parallax
or if like obviously okay so the way i
take it is this
soldier took the battery from this robot
and the robot should
have been like oh whoa it moves
wait i wonder if they made the katamari
uh like graphic on the tv yeah
well i'm just confused now because i
thought the rope i thought he took the
battery from the robot so the robot
would be powered down and i was thinking
if the robot's powered down then you
wouldn't have soldiers around it looking
all suspicious you'd have other mini
robots looking like
like they took they took our uh like the
i think
those old 10 robots are wind up he he
doesn't know what a battery is oh my god
dude that death stare at the end or it's
just like
so terrifying um this the render quality
is
amazing i don't know what do you guys
think this is the only this is the only
entry with a lava lamp
true does it get does it get upset from
union
uh i i'd pass i love it but i i could
pass i'll pass with you all this one
gets ups
from me but i i'm getting voted out
i i which is fine which is fine that's
how this works well
i love this one too this one's i'm torn
but for the sake of moving forward
let's bring it up okay drawn
congratulations
jonah with the beatles the beatleborgs
or the rats i thought they were beating
but i think they're rats they're
they're rats i love it i feel like this
would have been
i i don't know this one would have been
creepier had they all been like just
giant beetles
like moving out of the way well it's the
plague it's it's the speed
it's the play against the plague fair
enough for me it's the background
element
like the background element is just like
too slow it's not
like it would have been so good if it
was like the moon like but the moon's
over here
it's like you just i feel like you they
just didn't need this big old rat wheel
they needed like
it's too arbitrary that's my favorite
part yeah
it's like the the rat controls the wheel
of destiny or something
but uh i'd still i could still pass
i love it though i'll pass i love it
this one gets up to me
but oh he's leaving the town i think
he's dragging the bodies
out from the town yeah into the domain
of the rat lord
oh man well isn't that the job of the
people who would wear those masks
back in the plague yeah
i'll still pass i don't know i like it
yeah i mean i i i could pass red
i'm past fair enough
shout outs this person's name is also
jonah
that's about to say this is a 4k render
so it'll be a little laggy for y'all but
um
i for me this one is like 100 on the
render quality
and the atmosphere and like everything
yes
atmospherically very good uh
yeah render quality all like the little
foreground elements are literally uh
smoke so it's like it doesn't obscure
anything but it still gives you a sense
of motion
um the the raindrops only refracting
like
immediately around the lights to me make
it look like it's actually like
rain running down a piece of glass or
something that's a little weird
but like those little muddy footsteps
are the best thing i've ever seen so
yeah i'm gonna up this this is amazing
um this one is sick but i could pass on
it for top 50.
i'll pass on it game over game over
jordan
shout outs i love the render i'm glad it
made top 100
good good style um and a good contrast
from all the other styles so thank you
and the jordan oh i just realized you
have all these names alphabetically
sorted
oh
it's like this is the second time
there's another name that's the same
uh top 50 i mean listen this one's great
i love this one a lot
but it'd be hypocritical of me to
approve this one when i didn't approve
of all the other ones that
were also like referential you know i
agree
i'm down to pass on this one
yeah shout outs jordan good stuff man
i like that little like weird energy uh
shock wave that happens on this one yeah
i didn't notice that before yeah a cool
blast so like i was looking at this
right and
this thing whatever this person is
pulling is scooping up
it's scooping up this energy milk stuff
and it's going up through this tube and
you can see it going
super cool and i guess and it's giving
him some
and yeah he well he's spilling it
because that wire broke
so it is giving him some and then
this i guess is just the giant energy
ball
um that makes the world go round i guess
um see my problem is i'm not seeing any
sort of connection between the
foreground
story and the background story you know
it's like all those little like chain
linked
robot arm things doc ock in the
background like
that's all sweet but i don't see any
correlation between that and what this
needs to like interact with this in some
way to tell the story of how these
connect yeah
yeah so just because of that i'm going
to pass it's uh
protein assembly or something maybe yeah
protein harvest thing because like it's
really cool
it's a really cool idea um
i feel like i just could have had a
little bit more connection to it so i'll
pass on this one
um yeah this one's freaking awesome but
i'm gonna pass
joseph shout outs really sick stuff
again this one's really clever really uh
interesting idea
but i think it's too simple you know
it's like
i don't i don't feel like there's enough
going for it plus i don't know what the
story is
i mean i don't think there is a story
it's just kind of trippy the thing that
throws me
is this mix-a-mode model
oh model yeah
really it's like
freaking like jay from grand theft auto
russia or something like
it's really sweet and i like the idea
and it but it fits the scene really good
it does yeah it's really good um
i i'd say final fifty personally i do
too
it passed from me but i'm gonna pass
okay i'll move it up to that third tier
the uh the middle
like i'll put on the fighting gloves
tier and then we'll come back based off
of how much we have
yeah this one's definitely uh
i showed this one to a few uh guys at
the studio and
uh everyone had the same reaction to
this one she's like whoa yeah
this one gets enough for me it's like
yeah this one's great
bam it's like there's so much going on
but in the right way you know it's like
well the the sim that they have going on
is ridiculous
it's just the the spherical element is
definitely missing for me
on this one but this blows my mind uh
i'd say top 50.
it's there for me though i totally see
it and i i see the intent behind it
it's like it's there but it's it's it's
pushing the boundaries i i remember
the flashlight spotlight i to me that
totally
that totally counts game
but yeah i mean it moves up we could
talk about more sounds good
oh hey yeah
this green screen one is a favorite of
mine there's so much going on here that
i love
it also just looks real you know i love
it
so much cool style i love it so much
this gets the up for sure
of of the pants on the green screen
dudes you have a saggy crotch yeah
good stuff amazing
no doubt about it i love it yeah
ansel adams picture in my opinion i love
it so good
yeah there's like corpses in the snow
yeah skeletons or something like
really intense that's like a big boat i
love this whole frost look
sweet
top 50 what do we think i love this one
this one i feel like the color is just
too all over the place it's too uh
i feel like the color isn't focused
enough you know
that's what i like about it i love it
yeah i love
the color there's a there's a lot going
on i
compositionally it's just like
everything
is everywhere i don't know
i feel you yeah i feel same time it's
like it's very overwhelming yet there is
a circular composition to everything
everything like the way the uh
asteroid belt in the distance kind of
scoops up
into the mountains and the mushrooms
yeah yeah that's true
i'll i'll i'll say yes on this one
so yes for me let's bring it up all
right
also i hate jupiter
you know i like them blowing it up oh so
that that was the i see i see
this one's super dope the only thing
that bothers me about this is
the kit bash 3d buildings
not that there's anything wrong with
using kit bash elements i just
i don't know why i don't like those
assets and also that do those
come with the trees on them all right
now like the group now
so he added growth looks fantastic i i
like i like that
i could go either way on this one for
top 50. like
i want to hang out there like yes
look at the water somewhere in his feet
man that's that's so well done
you're right okay it gets the up yeah
that's sick
god dang 100
this speaks a lot like this one dude
this has story this has
we'll talk about later it has
everything burger man
i like this one a lot just because it
feels so vibrant like it feels like an
hdr
video you know it's like i love how
bright it feels while also how
like i don't know i feel like the grade
on it is just yeah
i love it i'm down for top 50.
i could pass on this one i could pass on
this one just because i don't get it
and it it's got it feels too arbitrary
you know like the images being displayed
on that circular screen
uh the giant apple watch like it it's uh
i don't know it's uh it's a it's a
nature simulator because he's in the
machine
you need your 20 minutes of nature and
also run this factory while you can
yeah and it crashes at the end of it
[Music]
that gets again incredible i'm about to
pass on this
all right those are fighting it's on
fight and tear okay
yeah it's in the fighting tear
this is a 100
it's very
it's so painterly dude it's like it
looks like it's straight out of a league
of legends or some
i don't know some like uh who makes
those games
yeah i want to know how they did this
like it looks like there's like a rib
cage or like a spine
in the architecture mm-hmm yeah
you can clean it and then project it
like you can go in there it's a great
look it's so gross
it's this is 100 for me
yeah it's a yes
i like this one a lot because i'm a
sucker for rigid body dynamics
yeah especially like big lego like
it's so satisfying to be able to just
like break a lego structure
yeah and have like a giant although i i
now that i'm looking at i am kind of
confused by the story here because it's
like
the the background breaking and all that
stuff is cool but like who's this person
in the foreground
they're fighting no they're fighting the
kid it's the well there's some army of
toys versus this kid this little baby
the only thing is that that person there
is is that a is that a toy the person
walking carrying the other
yeah the barbie it's ken it's like the
uh the like
plastic hair oh okay yeah okay sure sure
dude the only thing that bothers me
about this one is that the keyframe for
the hand animation
starts at the first frame of the video
oh
yeah ramps up
it still gets top 50 for me but i feel
you i love it's a
giant baby's head as the circular
element yeah it's great
i'll pass i'll pass on it
i i love this one just like vibe wise
and lighting
and everything but yeah i could i could
pass
it it's good it's just a little plain
i love all this plants i i feel like the
the glow is just right there's just
enough glow there's just enough cut off
um but yeah it's
there's no evolution to it really i mean
there's like the dude in the background
there
i guess at the very end of it but i
don't know what's going on yeah it's
it's great uh obviously mid top hundred
but luigi
shout outs man good stuff
100 million
percent
this is like yeah so this is a guy to go
up
i love this one a lot the detail work is
very good the the cloth simulation work
is really good the implication that he's
trying to reach that other
ribbon for whatever reason my biggest
complaints are i have no idea what that
that circular element is it just looks
like
smoke or a smoke ring it
i don't know it's a little arbitrary
yeah it looks like the thing from
arrival
yeah um this is
and other than that for me it's the fact
that the
the gradients and the color like
literally the the hue
is exactly the same as like one of the
most iconic shots from blade runner
2049. this like
literally is that exact same gradient
yeah but is that just what it looks like
inside a sandstorm here i'm gonna google
yeah i mean i feel like that's a that
can't be limited to just blade runner
like that
straight up what it looks like inside a
sandstorm this is so sick to me this is
like a hundred percent
100 million percent uh what do you guys
think
i say yes i like that this is really
tough all right
easy heck yeah
gorgeous love it yup top 50
yup for me yeah i'm down
yeah i my only complaint is i feel like
it's lacking texture detail
you know silhouette compositionally and
geometry wise there's a lot of cool
stuff going on but
uh i don't know i feel like i'd like to
see a little bit more detail on the
ground and the other
there's like not much bump you know ian
what do you think on this one
i i think it captures the feeling of
industrial like better than
anything i've ever seen but yeah at the
same time i feel like that's
mostly all it's doing okay um i'd say
it's top 50.
i agree yeah this one captures the like
old uh propaganda workforce vibes
for me i love the little elevator on
that uh
background building oh wow that's cool
yes that's sick
all right final final thoughts yes yay
or nay
yeah okay
is the spherical element like a snow
globe in the background yeah
i'm not quite sure what i'm looking at
this city future snow globe
i like this is great but honestly i
could pass on it
i love it i love all the little bits
yeah there's a lot going on it just
doesn't speak to me detail
okay martin shout outs
good stuff man great work
rand we're getting a little bit of wind
on your end
oh i mean yeah sorry it's cool i'll tell
you on that
you just turn your mic on when you're
talking or put your
is it yeah yeah yeah a little bit you
can put your hood up maybe
if you have put your hood on
oh yeah yeah i got windy all of a sudden
it's still coming in i i i like this one
but i could
i could pass just the background all the
different layers don't
totally gel for me a bit over
stimulating i agree
yeah i'm not i'm not a fan of this one
to be honest it's really cool
but at the same time
i love the weird lemon yeah the color is
very
weird for me um
i'll i'll pass i can pass on this one
yeah there's just a lot of like
sci-fi city you know only a few sci-fi
city renders can make it and
uh i think i'll pass on this one
i like the reveal of the plant though
when that blanket blows away i
i agree is that okay yeah i agree
but no yeah i passed too okay there's a
there's definitely a superior plant
reveal here
matteus shout outs man sick render
congrats on top hundred
i love this one this one's freaking
amazing um it's i can't believe wait
this is like wait you said this is
entirely
100 unreal engine wow dang man that's so
well done
caves man he's the master i'll i'll up
this
for sure yeah yeah this is a good one
cool
this one's also pretty sweet i love i
love the
the the fluid sim coming out of the the
the jar he's breaking free it's telling
a story you know
it's like and he actually has some
intent there it's not just like they're
breaking away he actually specifically
grabs the one in his head and breaks it
off
the cable snapping physics are really
rad yeah
yeah i dig it i'd say this is a would
have loved some more environment work
here yeah
yeah yeah i agree yeah it's a little
like
where the things are placed yeah and
like
the ground just feels like it's lacking
the ground element and like the screen i
can't tell if that's like
a window it looks like a window but
there's no bevel like there's no thick
bevel to it it's just like a
2d plane i guess i don't know i
this one's sick but i'll pass on top 50.
yeah i agree
um i don't know it's a yes for me i
think it's top 50 for me
ian uh i'd pass okay
okay shout out to ma m-a-d-u
i love i like this one a lot i love the
detail on the rocks
like yeah everything and that that
that splash that that wave
yeah i dig this one this is top 50 for
me
cool oh yeah sweet
i'm a sucker for miniatures
also those string lights they just they
read so well when they're slightly out
of focus like that
it feels the whole thing feels very cozy
it does um
for me though like story-wise i guess
he's bringing a bunch of pencils to be
sharpened and then what are they doing
with those pencils
they're in a war they're sharpening them
down they're
pencil sharpening uh world record speed
competition
nothing says war to me though also
notice how he knocks the truck off the
table with that little he kicks that
little
ruler and it knocks the truck off he's a
born killer
uh that was funnier than it's very
it's very photographic to me you know
like it looks
like the the depth of field is very
yeah it's very cinematic this lens flare
is killing
me though dude this like after effects
cc lens flare is like uh oh i see that
now yeah
i mean yeah i don't know i'm totally
totally attached to it
i just think it's very pleasing it is
very pleasing but for the sake of
moving on i'm down to the past on this
one yeah i could pass
mozart motez shout outs motez good stuff
again this one's super cool there's a
lot of like really cool contrast
going on i love the titan in the
distance just kind of like looking
uh back and noticing him i think this
one's just like a little blurry
a little like not as high-res not as uh
i don't know as crispy as i would like
it to be the clouds
clouds are very soft and like
i don't know this is right on the
lightning's a little weird
i guess i feel that oh i dig it i and i
love the reveal of the titan there and
the eyes
it feels so menacing yeah the mocap on
the
titan is just ridiculous i love it
so yeah something about being it makes
me feel small you know because it's like
there's something about being noticed by
something so huge that
i i feel is uh like
it it triggers my animal instinct a
little bit uh what do you guys think
yeah your name
yes uh yay yay
yeah i'll put it up yeah
i'd say 100 this is like peter's
favorite because he loves otters
it's not because i love otters i just
love how like
hard they went on this concept
how it's like such a weird random
concept but they
really followed through and took it to
like
oh my god is that it's amazing fox in
the background putting his guts back in
oh god it's going up for me
yeah this one's so this one's a favorite
he's dude put his guts back
in jeez he's like howling in pain
that's amazing this goes up these odds
don't care this one blows me away yeah
it's a good one also just the like the
character modeling and animation is
crazy yeah i'm down and this little
hedgehog
just coming in hot just like
yeah now that i'm realizing it every
single one of those animals is different
yeah there's a weasel a little like a
ferret maybe
that's a good one great material work
too
damn yeah stick sticking out of mine
i love this one i just wish i knew what
was going on
this this is a classic one that i feel
almost works
okay no i figured it out this one the
reason why
i don't think this one should continue
is because this works about the same
this works just as well as a still image
as it does
the actual video interesting totally
you know it's like nothing really
changes over the course of the shot
there's not really uh
and it's so striking from a single image
standpoint like i could pick any frame
from this
and it's like that's a sweet desktop
background
but in context as a video i don't think
it works
i'll pass on it yeah it's amazing
amazing
uh go ahead ian
oh yeah i i could pass i'm just really
digging all the little stuff on the
carpet me too and the person being
drugged in the back it's almost like
their soul
like they died and their soul was like i
got you oh
super cool yeah
i love how the light source is the soul
you know like
yeah it's really cool yeah but yeah i'm
a pass
i'll pass
y'all gonna pass ian peter oh yeah yeah
yeah
okay
see this one finally works for having
the pose work for wind you know like
there's been several where the pose was
justified for like the wind you know
like oh he's just trying to fight into
the wind but i've never
felt that intensity until this shot yeah
this is a
it feels really justified 100 for me
even though i feel like the fire is
completely separate from the wind
you know the fire is uh
true i like these holding the child in
front of him
to kind of protect himself from anything
that might fly
yeah this is a very dangerous situation
baby bumper
this is up for me i think we can move on
it's freaking great
i love it yeah
i love the idea i love i love the
the concept here i just feel like the
execution of the concept
isn't top 50. i could pass on it i love
it but um
i really love the vibe but
it's a breath of fresh air
yeah that is very true something that
always this is just a personal
gripe of mine it always bugs me when
there's a
12 frames per second element moving at
24 frames per second
you know what i mean no you mean like so
everything let's see so like it's
something yeah
or 12 seconds moving across the screen
at 24.
so you hear how yeah the the environment
is on ones but the characters are on
twos
exactly so you get a little sliding yeah
which is just like a ripple the animated
spiderman movie did that a ton
um yeah but they did it very selectively
you know
right yeah it's interesting this one's
great but i think uh
it's time to put it to bed i'm down
yeah so right now we have
a top one two three four five six seven
eight
34 35 36 37 38.
2 4 6 8 10 2
4 6 8 22
left with like three ties do you know
which one's at the top let's just keep
going
this one uh
i don't know i like a lot about it
uh
i like the composition for the orb or
the the spherical element
you know it's uh compositionally it's
pretty good but
again it's just not speaking to me i'm
not sure why
yeah same i could probably pass on i
love that train
oh yeah i'm gonna pay
him all right i'll pass on this one i
guess
yeah all right let's see what we can do
without peter if three of us
like it we'll move it up top 50 what do
you think
i i could pass i could pass
top 50 as well yeah
yeah i'll pass it's listen i i this
one's dope because
it's able to use this giant emissive
texture in the background to
light the ground in the foreground and
it really accentuates the
the the rain hitting the ground and the
use of silhouettes
it really feels like we're you know in
the middle of a city on a rainy day like
the
this that taxi cab looks really good and
the guy having to like
pull all of his stuff while this big you
know through the rain is this big
reader board in the background is like
hey
it's sunny like that's
plus the dichotomy of like the sun
shines on everyone but it's very
obviously not a shiny day
it is funny yeah i can still pass on it
though for top 50.
yeah i could pass are those guys taking
a selfie oh yeah
uh wren what do you think
ah this is a weird one
it's like if i start breaking down the
details of why i think it's good
i start realizing it's pretty dang good
but at the same time i don't know i
don't love it
i'm gonna pass i don't love it okay i'm
sorry pedro
amazing love your vibe
this one's top 50 for me
i like it a lot there's so much going on
here that i just think yeah
this one is this one again got like a
little sci-fi marketplace going on i
like that there's a
there's a story here it i haven't really
seen many that
added an additional character in
addition to the
uh the in the mocap yeah like
it's true i dig the world going on here
i think this is like
10 out of 10 for world building it's not
in your face it's not over the top
it's pretty subtle um
and it plus those little uh those red
those orange curves coming in to
complete that that
yeah the space junker or like the yeah i
just think yeah this one is like
it your eyes aren't darting all over the
place it's a really clean
like your first look is here at the
astronaut and then you're looking here
at the foreground
yeah and it kind of i like that it feels
like you can actually like jump in
and like explore it a little bit like
it feels like there is stuff kind of
happening off to either yeah
yeah i dig it the freaking little gnats
up in the light too
oh yeah both those foreground characters
kind of like turning the look a little
bit
uh that that robot ship in the back
that's kind of like lifting off is that
a road is that a giant robot
ladybug it kind of looks like it
kinda well it goes up i don't know i i
digress a lot
absolutely
this is top 50 for me this is always so
startling when it shows up
it's just so lush so he's chasing the
like red butterfly
i just can't help but feel like that
little tree element in the foreground is
a disservice
here it's like i feel like it blocks too
much of the
foreground stuff going on i would agree
can't see the force man for the trees
like i i want to see more about what's
going on with like the little weird like
blue stuff
attached at his feet but i spend more
than half the shot being occluded by
the trees that's my biggest gripe with
it
but i don't know if that takes away the
fact that it's
one of the most beautiful renders of
them all
i i want to i want to bring it up i'll
bring it up yeah
what are we doing now top this is top
50. no we're still on top 50.
i i like how clean this one is and the
composition's really really clean
but i i could pass on it yeah
i could pass i feel the same it feels
amazing but
raphael shout outs man
man this one's cool i love the technical
uh
skills being shown here you know with
the the plants growing
um i just don't know what this
background
thing is like i guess it's a rock but
i feel like there could have been more
going on back here
like i don't know why i don't love love
it like it seems like it should check
every box for me but
there's something yeah i can't put my
finger on it
i think i've grown a little tired of the
um
you know apocalypse last surviving plant
thing there are there are a lot of those
the implied story of the robot
having both like the blue haze but also
the yellow haze to me are competing a
little bit which i think is like
compositionally
where it's not totally jelly okay like
it's like a
tie down okay but i love that big
robot hand so much it's very uh yeah
hyper light drifter
yeah um i could go either way on this
one
i'm gonna pass yeah i could pass but i
feel bad me too
i just yeah exactly there's like more
guilt for passing on this one
i know but that's the way it is we gotta
pass on ever on 95 of these
like like peter was saying there's this
dude carrying uh this plant
in the back and it's like you know
there's one plant shot that i feel
really nails it and i think we're gonna
see that here in a bit and if i have to
choose between the two i'm gonna choose
that one over this one so i'm gonna pass
on all right regin
shout outs congrats cause i saw that one
on twitter yeah right
this is one of my favorite background
elements ever
it's so good
i like that they're like they're taking
all the water or something but he also
has those little sloshing bottles on his
wagon
i love this i'm pretty sure that's an
image simulation in the back there
they've got that vortex going on uh and
so it's technically a smoke sim but he's
got
got it matched to look like it's the
water coming out notice how it like
i don't know whether that's a shading
thing happening in the render
versus uh like a post
color correction type deal going from
like the
the frothy white at the bottom to dark
going into the orb
i've definitely got some oblivion vibes
from this this isn't up for me
i i like it a lot oh yeah yeah
absolutely sweet i like
it yeah
this one i love all the style in this
one but i'm gonna i'm gonna pass on this
one it's
i love i love the concept of the fantasy
aspect but i feel like it's a little too
arbitrary yeah
the only thing that doesn't check out
for me is the yeah
agreed that yeah the in the leg
not splashing the water it's beautiful
but i could pass
yeah yeah i could pass sebastian
sick work man good stuff
i'll just put that up why does this one
work so well
i don't even know it just does uh the
color
i think it's because the orbs offer a
bit of a leading line
down to the uh the character the cloth
sim dude
the lighting the wind i feel like i can
feel the wind that he's
uh running into just due to the cloth
like really just whipping out back
behind him
like the cloth yeah it's the wind it's
the lighting it's the
uh it's the blotchy diffused sunlight
yeah they're like you have a strip of
sunlight hitting your character but the
foreground
is naturally vignetted by the cloud yeah
yeah it's a natural yet sick absolutely
the shaded side of the sphere off in the
distance that's 100
that goes up for sure yeah
oh wow okay so especially comparing them
these two back to back this one feels
like the camera's not even moving
it does yeah there's like not enough
foreground detail
to really tell me that there's motion
going on so it just kind of ends up
looking noisy
yeah i agree i agree
i think that that being said there's
like some really cool atmospherics going
on right over the top of the ground
yeah your eye is drawn to the top of the
frame not the subject
that's true yeah i could pass yeah my
favorite bits are that all the icicles
and the smoke coming out of that burning
one on the in the back left
oh yeah yeah but i i could i could pass
this is like great environmental work
but i feel like it's not enough
of a good use of the prompt sandre i
love your vibe man good stuff
very good stuff uh
yes this one's
this one's a favorite of mine i like it
a lot you know something about having
like the lone warrior hero
leading the pack of all the other dudes
and
you know it makes sense to have this
pose he
he's literally hunched over so that he
doesn't get shot by an arrow
justification is amazing and the the
lighting
the render quality this is a hundred
percent for me
freaking sick oh yeah
this is the one this one sticks out my
memory a lot this is the freaking one
dude
this has the best reveal and i feel like
it has the best color palette of all of
the
the post apocalyptic plant i agree it is
like the very beginning of it we see
like this skeleton sitting there
and then it's like a dead tree skeleton
is life yeah so
like there's a little electrical outlet
in there too
it's just like it's great wait hold up
is that skeleton
it's oh man there's okay that there's
those two skeletons are telling a story
a person died first and it was a loved
one and they're holding on to him but
then he also died or she also died
oh my god yeah they were eating all the
peaches from their little uh their fruit
tree and they ran out of pieces
yeah and they're revealed plus i love
death to life something about that
window like the way it's designed really
makes it feel huge
like a little walkway yeah yeah
i love those walkways we'll come back to
this one
for sure
oh yes
man this one's like it's pretty well
detailed but it's just like
it depresses me too much i have a pass
on it
i love the spherical element yeah it's
it's good it's like the escape yeah
definitely
um but yeah i'll pass on it for top 50.
rough man
tommy shout outs man i'll pass on this
one too
for top 50. i just i don't know i just
don't mind with the style on this one
i love the style i actually really like
like the background with the clouds and
the mountains and that like
the trees all kind of mix them together
i'll put it up we'll put up in to the
fighting
fighting deer i don't know i'm passing
on it
we'll move it up to the to the fighting
deer
also my my mic is going to go out
at some point guys um it's a
because it's a lapel so i'm like
it's going to go off so i'm going to
switch mics in a second there's another
one chilling here
so when that happens i'm assuming f will
blast through the chat
top 50 what do we think man this one's
cool this one has like
the use of uh the moonlight as a rim
light
works really well yeah i love the
lighting on this one
yeah cool i'll move it up yes yeah this
i'd say yeah on this one
man man this one's this one's pretty
dope
i wish i mean it's every time i see
fire i wish i saw smoke you know it's
like
yeah true yeah i mean for me
that's a quote every time i saw fire i
wish i saw smoke
that'd be great this one's great i just
love the justification for the mocap
data
but i think i'll have to pass on it for
top 50.
so yes for me i just feel like i can
hear the soundtrack to this
just like i feel like this one here i i
almost feel like it's kind of cliche to
say but like i wish the moon was
big like the moon is just this tiny
little element off in the distance but i
feel like
this shot in particular it would have
felt more grand if the moon was like
giant in the actual spherical element i
see what he's kind of going for with the
composition
between the hill and the wings of the
dragon but
yeah would have worked better if it was
the moon could have gone big moon on it
but
like but like at a certain focal length
the moon is going to be
an actual size in the in this this is a
personal thing
just like i love the dragons
like the subsurface the translucency in
the in the cheeks
right before the fire comes out oh
that's true that's that's a really cool
detail
i do like this one a lot i wouldn't be
opposed to moving this up
this is a yes for me let's let's bring
it all right what's up what's up
i think this is the best nighttime
sci-fi world
personally i agree and there's just
everywhere you look there's little
things
happening yeah great lighting
and i love the implication that
mcdonald's is just going to be around
forever
well i feel like that crow would get out
of the rain though
get out of here crow which one this guy
chilling oh yeah
well birds don't fly in the rain i think
he's a spy
he's a spy that's hilarious
all right that one's up good job willie
johan is next
i love this one i love i love it yeah
that's three
you guys really love this one yeah it's
the color be honest
i hear you we'll get back to it wren
dislikes happiness and colors
it's just i don't know it's it's too all
over the place
this one i like a lot this one's a yes
we've got some really cool detail going
on
i love that little robot that stops by
and says hey he's chilling
yeah he's like yo what's up this one's a
top 50 for me yeah it's up
jeez
the detail and the texture work here is
is very good and i love the the bright
uh top light there uh illuminating the
atmospherics
ian you said this is your truck right
it's a it's an asset yeah
is the whole thing that is pushing your
asset it's been it's been modified yeah
okay this one is incredible
yeah but i could i could i could
probably if the truck had more character
if the truck had more personality
like maybe like even if it was as simple
as like the back of it was scraping on
the ground you know like it's just
barely hovering
uh it would it would do more for me but
right now it's just like it's just
placing the shot
yeah this one's like right on the edge
for me but i could probably pass on this
one
yeah i mean i'm not gonna fight you guys
i do love this one though it would be a
yes for me
i i love that ship in the background
kind of rising up
uh i'm i'm gonna pass on it okay
all right shout outs
to indie story
one moment all right so let's tally it
up
we're getting close
let's see how we through to the top
um let me do a little count here
all right two four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen sixteen seventeen eighteen
nineteen twenty twenty one twenty two
three
quarter five six twenty 27 28 29 30 31
32 33 34 35 36 or 77 38 39
right 40 one two three four five or six
or eight seven or eight 49
we need one of the fighting tiers to
come
down for top 50. one of these three
which of these three
do we want to take with us
i like the uh the the wheel the
the screen wheel one
coffee factory the best out of those
three
i i take out the checkerboard you would
you would take the checkerboard with us
to top 50.
oh we get to pick which one goes which
one goes up
oh pick one that goes up
yeah the rat race one i'd bring out rat
race okay
peter the meat meat factory yeah i do
the middle one there this middle one
yeah this okay
sounds good well then the other two
thank you for your service
75 which is pretty solid let me just do
a little house cleaning here and we'll
get in
i need a cookie because i'm hot damn it
is
2 p.m well i'm starving um i'm gonna
throw out something here
yes uh you can still reveal
the
up 15. i mean i'm
i'm down to go to the top 15
that's fine with me yeah i if we can
pull that off i think we could pull that
off
let's see i mean yeah because it's going
long you know
let's see all right let me
do a little house cleaning here yeah
it's late
okay yeah we've been here for three
hours at this point
i'm going to switch my mic real quick
and here let's
ndsa it's 2 am
we on top 50 now um let me do
this quick window capture deal
like i don't know part of me thinks we
should uh
so we have the top 50. what if we just
go straight into
revealing what the top 15 is i'm down
and then we can check we know what the
top 15 is
yeah and then we can go top five from
there that that
sounds like the most reasonable thing to
do with everybody's time
because what uh a little bit of the back
end reveal here basically we spent all
of this time narrowing it down to the
top five but the top
15 is where we ended up like from
narrowing it from top 15 to top five was
where we spent most of our time debating
because now we're like literally
deciding which ones we want to fight
over
and you you actually uh sent us a video
of the top 15 so we can see like which
ones
were our favorites uh looking at them at
high quality
and i say we just go through one by one
and when we get to the one that's like
in the top like all right this one's
moving on okay then we get to
yeah agreed so then let me uh let's hit
top 15 then
give me one moment here i'm just gonna
switch out this screen here
and we'll make it happen thank you guys
for your patience and uh
for hanging in with with me for so long
um you guys's time is
very valuable so it means a lot you guys
are doing this with me
i'm actually reviewing the video real
quick just so i refresh my memory on
what did make it to the top
yeah for sure that'd be nice as well oh
yeah
so yeah like brenda's saying we met two
nights ago we did all of this
in private and we came up with our top
five and it came down to the top 15 like
ren is saying so i think what we'll go
what we'll do is we'll actually choose
the top 15 right here from the top 50
and then we'll whittle it down to the
top five
it's late for a lot of y'all and we've
been going for a while so
um just making things a little easier on
everybody
so we've seen many renders up until this
point
okay so we're at top
15 one moment
i'm gonna switch out this uh
this card here for the little top 15
bam okay
so let's pull up our top 15.
like the moment i see it i'll we'll say
yes and if we don't see it we'll just be
like this was good but
sorry like this all right ready yeah
this one
amazing uh oh let me hold on give me a
second
yeah this one's super solid i love
everything about it just not top 15.
same super sick render yeah super sick
render
good times caleb we love you shout outs
carlos same to you buddy good times
this is the topic top 15 yeah
carlos guys what are you taught there is
no peter cut what are you talking about
god damn it are they going on about the
the satisfying render
oh it's coming it's it's coming
this one is very good but i don't think
it made the cut yeah
david good stuff man very good stuff
dd good times not top 15 right
no rest in peace this one is a yes
donald on the other hand yo
top 15. yeah uh enrique enrique every
time i see this one i'm like man that's
so good but it didn't make it
yeah shout outs man good times
oh my god i love this one so much the
same yeah
didn't make it but it's so good same
with this one didn't make it
very close very very close this one's
very good
very close very close
and very close so close we're just
looking at a fun highlight reel at this
point
also somebody said that the robot is
reacting to a little burst of flames in
the background
oh what oh yeah
that's cool okay i guess there is some
motivation there it's too subtle
mm-hmm this is yeah that's grg
um yeah this one i wish had a little bit
more
yeah a little bit more i wish it was
easier to understand the character yeah
dude this is this would have been so
much better
i mean this one's already so good but
that one would have been so much better
had there just been a little bit more
going
on you know like had like we've been
able to see the feet like clinch or
something like that implying that
he's like pinching one off or something
i don't know
i like how clean it is it's very clean i
dig it
jason also same with this yeah didn't
make it very close
the santa monica pier in my opinion this
is like cool
super sweet shout outs
they nailed the fire oh man this one's
also good jayden
this one i don't think made it did you
this one i don't think also made the top
15. really
surprising yeah it was very good but it
didn't make it
same for john yeah shout outs to john
and jonah
super sweet thanks for shout out to
jonah hopping in
this one yeah yeah this is very good
as did that one top 15. man as did this
top 15. let's go congrats to all you
guys
real close i do love this one
and yeah good stuff it's so weird to be
in a position of like
sorry you didn't make it and every
single one of these are incredible this
one yeah
this one's yeah this is the top top 15.
it's so weird this is like futuristic
but i get a very distinct like edgar
allan poe
like feel from it um this one didn't
make it
i love it this one a favorite of mine
that one didn't make it top
15 son loic lo loic
congratulations
lucas top 15
top 15 for lucas
so sick do you ever see that movie sky
captain in the world of tomorrow
100 yeah yeah i got vibes from that one
there
man this one oh i love this one so good
um we're breaking hearts
right now yeah all the hearts are just
shattering right now i'm so sorry
yes yeah it's like nick amazing awesome
um so this one this one
this one top 15. this one made it just
because it nailed the the feel of
intensity you know like yep yeah
it feels like i'm in the middle of a
hurricane we can get into like a
reasoning for everything once we choose
it all
yeah was this top top 15 we chose no
it didn't make it dang that was like
must have been like 16
oh yeah no it came down to this that was
the final one for sure this is a
uh this one made it
this one shout outs man no it did not
we didn't okay no this one does this one
heck yeah this one just it feels so
sharp and clean yeah it's amazing
100 percent as did this one this one 100
yeah 100
this one too i think these next two
yeah yeah top 15 baby
this was a pass for top 15. great it's
good it's just like not enough going on
you know
same deal
i know i know
well that was it that was the top 15.
let's count it up two
three four five six let's see
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
we have fourteen i see one made it i
think i think it did
no definitely it's not in this video at
least oh
what's in the video what's in the top 15
wait i think this top 15 is actually a
top 14. really
i promise we're not making this up off
the top of our heads we did all this
work beforehand two nights ago
i'm glad we did
i mean we are the judges we can decide
this now
i i'd bring the if there was only 14 i'd
bring the water one up
same yeah i'd agree with that let's
bring the water one up water world sun
yeah all right so our top 15 i'm going
to play them
back to back here um give me is that 14
no no it's 15. it's a true 15 right
there give me one moment i'm just gonna
combine these videos here briefly
uh let's see
delete gaps bring to the front
and here we have our top 50 get a
battery for my laptop okay i'm going to
switch my mic too
i'm going to switch this mic out
peter wanna want to tell us some science
facts
oh man that's so broad what's it like
specifically like what feels good
like what's your what's your coolest
lightning fact like facts about
lightning oh
i got a fact about lightning yeah um
all right i'm gonna have to demonstrate
this if you're
in a storm that has lots of thunder and
you start feeling your hair standing on
end
[Music]
you go like this with your heels
together
so the current if it hits the ground can
go through your feet
and doesn't go through your body and you
put your hands over your ears
so your eardrums don't blow out and
that's basically to protect yourself
from a lightning strike airbender [ __ ]
so i climbed a little like a lava butte
in the middle of like a pumice field
with uh my fiancee one of her friends
and there was a lightning storm and i
was freaking out and i was like
as long as nobody's hair stands up on
end we're fine
and i turn around at one point and
i don't know if you can see this but and
they're like oh my god
they're like it's the wind i'm like this
is not the wind
down the mountain
oh you made the right call to get get
out of there that's no joke oh my god
zapped that's insane
wow i actually threw i was holding one
of those like walking sticks like the
metal climbing sticks because this
really steep hill
and i chucked it i was like i'm holding
the lightning rod
exactly i threw it at one of them
actually though
in my panic it was
that's hilarious strike you not me
uh i gotta ask the chat how do i sound
do i sound okay
do i sound okay to you guys i guess
that's good to me sound good yeah
all right you sound exactly the same
dude everyone's like willie for 15.
dude willie willie's amazing willie's
amazing i know there's going to be
people who disagree with the top five
but hey that's just the way it is you
know this is the four of us coming
together to do our best
which ones will so i'm wondering how we
should go about this next part here
because we are kind of going along on
time
should we just kind of talk about each
one of these top 15 individually a
little bit what
works what we like about it and then
just reveal the top five
yeah yeah and then we'll decide which
ones actually win because
i have a feeling that's going to take
some debate that's a good idea let's go
through each one of these let's just
talk about what we like about them
and let's reveal the top five um
and what we love about the top five and
then we'll figure out the order of those
top five
sound good so this first one here yeah
uh we're good to go yeah so this first
one
my favorite part is the actual color
like the
the orange is the right type of orange
the blue is the right type of blue
it's it's very uh you know it's very
i don't know how to describe it dark
thematically but
also like maybe a little too visually
dark it's the only thing that's kind of
drawn it back for me
i wish i i could see a little bit more
detail especially the whole like top
left quarter of the image there's like
essentially nothing yeah
i love the uh like the body dump up here
it's absolutely incredible
yeah i just dig these feel that it's
actually like
several bodies and not just like some
weird big shape
and the guy carrying up some more of
them behind
yeah personally yeah i wish it was a
little bit
clearer in the foreground but at the
same time that does make way for you to
pay attention to the background and see
what's going on
yeah it is focused it's very very
focused
i think that's why it made it to the top
15. i weirdly like the balance between
the foreground and the
and the background but yeah i agree it's
just a little a little too
dark to me and just like the separation
of the colors is almost too distinct
like it's just to me the moon is
a little too blue and all the other
lights are just a little too orange
that's true i dig it yeah i like the
colors i i i feel like it's getting that
that cinematic
uh teal orange look like the right way
it's not like overly done like overly
color corrected
yeah i feel like teal and orange looks
the best when it's you get the tail and
orange in camera and then just push it
further
in grading
right moving on um
i love this because the character
is the probably one of the most unique i
also love your lighting yeah
i love the world character
feels very alien all the little jumping
grasshoppers
like running away are super great every
time i watch you through i see another
little guy
it's just very unique and i i think it
all it all ties together
in a really cool way
like all the flowers look kind of like
little gas pods or something
i don't know there's like little spheres
now this one i think gets like a
visceral reaction from all of us
um yeah it's dude
like i'm just like my jaw's on the floor
with this one it's freaking crazy
this one works yeah i'm beginning to
wonder if this isn't a sim
if it's all hand animated i think i
think it is like if you look at any
given one the keyframes are actually a
little like
wonky and some of them are glitching out
but that actually makes them seem
kind of more nightmarish yeah yeah it's
a it's that like sort of uh you know
that that scary movie type feel with
like the ring you know where
like the inconsistent movement adds to
the creepiness
and the horror aspect jerking and
lumbering
also i love the color i love the the red
and yellow
uh side by side here
it also said old boy oh yeah
the the hammer fight yeah so i forget
which of you said like the
pointing out there is a little bit of a
light at the end of the tunnel
right let's go back to the tunnel shot
real quick
or not you know it's cool i got you
you guys see it yeah
also is that what is that in the
foreground there i kind of kept at first
i thought it was like broken glass like
a broken window but now it looks like it
might be a
mound of something
i think it's more shaving cream
it all fits together this one this green
screen shot
it's so well done this is a favorite of
mine yeah
about this there's something to look at
it's not too distracting anywhere but
there's
always something to look at the detail
is perfect the render quality is really
nice
the circular element is very unique um
and it's totally just like the meta
you know on this yeah yeah it's so meta
they
he even has the the the gray and chrome
ball
and the color palette and all the the
stickers
on the uh on the crate sir oh yeah
totally oh yeah
and i'm pretty sure that's a rococo suit
he's wearing
i think it is it looks like the straps
yeah oh yeah
i love it i'm i'm personally amazed by
the fabric material
like the sheen is perfect the roughness
amount yeah because that's not just like
a a
glossy or a rough texture that's like
or material it's like a specifically a
fabric
material in the way that the light bends
around it
yeah i freaking dig this one also i love
how the characters from
uh willy wonka and the chocolate factory
are in the background there
left the little white thing he gets
miniaturized in the white
room that's funny what's what's he
scattering are those just leaves i guess
those are just leaves
uh i can't tell it looks like leaves
yeah they're leaves
also when we it
i don't if we really get down to it
though
i don't i don't get what the actual
purpose is here like why are there a
bunch of green screen
dudes when they're just getting no cap
like there's no camera you know like
have you ever been on a set where they
were doing vfx
green everything
yeah the meta part speaks way louder
than anything else here for me and then
on top of that i really love the use
of the orb as a foreground element yeah
ren we are the camera
you you're looking this is the footage
this is the footage
all right moving on dude this one's very
good i love
this the use of texture here like the
snow that it feels
like there's depth like subsurface depth
to the snow it almost looks like cotton
balls
yeah the render quality here is like
next to none
freaking crazy like that frost
especially in the foreground kind of out
of focus
the whole thing feels so tangible yeah i
agreed
yeah the red lights like i feel like if
i could just wipe my finger across the
ground and be like
yeah absolutely absolutely amazing
this one i love everything about this
one because it has
story there's actual purpose for the
mocap data
um the visual composition and lighting
is perfect the render quality is perfect
there's a story going on like this
this fire is on all cylinders for me
is that there's a lot of invisible
lights on the scene
huh like above the car the cop car and
like the rim light on the dude
lots of uh nice lighting work yeah
i love how arbitrary some of this is
like the little the the blue orb sitting
there the the yard ornament
it's like it feels so out of place and i
feel like that's the point i hate that
yard ornament
body thing they got it at a
a yard sale somewhere and stuck it in
the front yard yeah
the worst part of the render is that
darn yard ornament dude i'm like
no no no no it's the best that's
funny because it feels like so gaudy but
also like notice the alien light coming
out of the bedroom there like what's
going
on in that bedroom oh yeah that's a good
point
and just the harvest and also it's a
subtle detail here but the mere fact
that they put the word harvest on that
giant sphere in the distance
implies so much like are they about to
send this person on the gurney or this
alien whatever it is uh this corpse to
this
that that sphere like i do think it
might be a direct
reference to something i'm doing a
stream with some some folks
but i don't know when it's wrapping up
but very soon
very soon i'll say like probably in the
next 30 minutes
yeah you're fine ian well you could hear
me just then yeah
oh i'm sorry i turned the little uh
volume no you're fine you're fine
you're good no worries so yeah we love
this one also i love how the
uh the dude in the back is like just
taking a big hit on a cigarette like all
in the day's work
yeah so this one
i love the world i love the lighting and
i love just sitting here trying to
figure out exactly like
what this crazy world is
yeah like it feels like there are weird
rules and i don't understand
it but like it definitely feels like it
exists i love the melted one in the
foreground
i i can't remember the name of it but
there's this d
uh game called star finder and there's
this race of
aliens that are basically just made out
of like bones and all of their
architecture looks
exactly like this this looks straight
out of that it feels very inspired by
that at the very least
but i love the yeah it's just
it's weird you know [ __ ] animating the
people
i don't know it's like i think they're
the life source because when that guy
dies that the spore falls
oh yeah but he's not dying from anything
so i don't know what
yeah but yeah i love the visual color
world about this one it's really cool
people are saying it's based on a comic
the word geiger h.r geiger maybe h.r
geiger that's a
the guy okay art for alien designer of
alien
[Music]
this one i love the freaking fog
i love the atmosphere i love the color i
love the render quality
i love the claw sim i love the light uh
in the helmet it's a such a good focal
point this one
is like so much for me i love it it
draws your eye in the right way
yeah like it reads immediately and then
it just stays
solid yeah this one's killer
so good now this one boy
this is one that i have a weird
relationship with because my immediate
reaction is hell yeah this one's awesome
but the more i start really looking at
it the more i'm just kind of like i
don't know
it uh it does it it is
it does kind of just read his noise
especially with the lights in the
background just kind of blinking and the
fire completely not reacts
the the wind i love the blinky lights
but it works you know like
yeah it it it has to me this one has
everything too it's the story it's like
emotion uh huge on the atmosphere
the lighting is like i guess just what
it needs to be um
it's hard to convey intensity you know
it's like it's one thing to set up a
shot that's pretty
but it's another to really make it feel
intense
yeah this one succeeds regardless yeah
there was when i saw the prompt i kind
of pictured
something like that and this is the one
that's like
the only one that really yeah made it
work yeah i agreed
this one uh i love the world on this
it it feels very vibrant very fresh um
so alive so alive yeah and so real like
you get this old little lady walking
past the main character
um i love the lighting in it i love the
color it draws the eye so well it has so
many things
going for this that like i'm i'm all
about this one
yeah it reminds me of star wars and that
all of the characters are so
unique and feel so grounded mm-hmm
yeah really yellow that's my favorite
part a little yellow tubes on that
foreground person
like the subsurface scattering on those
are sick
also sorry
um i mean blue and yellow are
complementary and i love that their
suits
are that way you know it's just like a
subtle subtle thing but
that choice you know of choosing
uh i don't know i'm a big fan of
complimentary colors you could see it in
a lot of my own artwork but
this one's this one's uh cool in that
regard yeah yeah it was just about to
say like
the blue and yellow and then you get
kind of that red from the ship back
there
and the red of the little swoopy swoop
kind of has a primary colors five which
i
dig yeah i love that they have this like
weird 1950s
style like piece of furniture on their
back like some sort of radar
situation like it feels like yeah they
did crash land there and they're looking
for something
is that guy looking at his phone he's
like i i look at he's looking at a
checklist
like this guy's checking him into a hut
that he's going to stay at i see
oh that's so cool oh i kind of read it
as like
uh the other guy is having to haul their
their stuff and
the guy in front is just kind of like
texting looking at a map or something
trying to figure out where to go that's
funny but like obviously putting off the
hard work to the other guy
i guess that makes the most sense i
thought of him as like a landlord but
he's also in a very similar suit so i
think
that's so cool it's just the unhelpful
roommate
also wait go back go back real quick is
that e.t
uh in the this little thing it might be
yeah it might be e.t
you realize is that e.t e.t phone home
e.t carrying an electric bass on his
man this one's awesome i i still can't
wrap my hat at my head
exactly around why this one works
so well it's the lighting it's like
lighting it's it's flying
from above and so you get like lighting
from both sides in a really nice way
yeah and it's also like the coolest
spherical element i think i love that
so much
like the city is detailed there's just
so much detail
it's a big-ass nose trimmer
this one uh render quality and lighting
for me is like
10 out of 10. this one meets a very very
good middle ground between
like something that's photorealistic but
also painterly
yeah i love the just the rocks and the
puddles stretching off to the horizon
like this one looks like a uh one of
those like pre-rendered game cinematics
that they use in commercials before the
game comes out for destiny
i'm getting some destiny vibes yeah man
i love their like
uh they're stacking or you know like
these orbs how they go off into the
distance i
i love that so much yeah and acts as
leading lines like just the
the position of those orbs even though
there's not actually any lines though
it's uh it's still leading you your eye
towards the person
yeah yeah and that middle one also
frames up the person
like in a little composition like it's
like a frame within a frame kind of
yes like this is one that would still
work really well if you were to crop
in to just like his feet and the top of
that that little sphere
that's true
and this one uh is so good just because
of how unique it is no one else
yeah and close to kind of like i don't
know
yeah the top five that we're going with
um
each one of them shines in their own way
and they're all they're all like maxed
out on most of the levels but
like you guys will see here that like
each one is very specific
um and they're hitting they're firing on
all cylinders but
a lot of them like like this one in
particular just the justification for
the mocap data um is so freaking good
very similar to the uh like the harvest
one like this one right here
the the justification for the mocap data
it's just
freaking top notch and it's a beautiful
render
love the lighting it's just looks like
300 or something
it's very very well executed
and also still has a very good you know
consistent art quality
a consistent art style across the board
yeah and compositionally it just reads
really clear
oh man this one this one's so good
yeah this
i think it's it's hard not
to like i don't know it's it's just
obvious like look at this
it's crazy every bit was given so much
love oh
yeah pretty wild freaking crazy
um and then we have our our water scene
for that's
that's the 15 here that's what we're
having to choose between for the top
five um also again
notice the use of color a lot of
complementary yellow and blue yeah
the cyan is a good choice making the the
diver
wear yellow outfit and and whatnot it
stands out
in the right way
all right so those are our top 15 y'all
and
we have already chosen the top five how
do you guys want to reveal it
we just i i say clint you have a list of
the top five
go straight to them be like this is uh
one through five of the top five but we
haven't decided which one is number one
we haven't yeah okay yeah okay
well you just said it no so
so basically the idea is of these 15
we're gonna choose five
um they're they are in no particular
order
we're gonna figure out the order once i
tell you the top five
all right and that'll be basically the
end
of our journey today uh it's been a long
stream
i hadn't peed yet that's gonna be sick
um oh boy i hadn't eaten yet either
that's gonna be cool too
um so here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
change the little title card here
to top five
the champions this is the champion
section
um and let me just switch out this here
so we don't get a bunch of lag
like we have been getting bear with me
a little window capture
resolve and we're going to get these top
five out to you
in like one minute
and i'll go through i'll basically go
through
the top five and i'll tell you why that
we
we all agreed collectively we got
together two days ago
we did exactly what you saw us do just
now but privately
um as a nice little rehearsal and i'm
gonna reveal to you guys the top
five here and our decisions on why we
collectively agreed
we gave each one a point we picked our
personal top five
um three of those went to the top uh
automatically and then basically we had
to
fight and argue over the last two
resulting in our top five um ryan did
you have anything because we had a top
seven yeah we had something
that's right top five but uh real quick
i i feel like
are you before we even discuss anything
revealing the top five straight up
oh it says ren's muted wait hold on
am i still meeting it's even possible i
can hear you
ren give me levels can you not hear me
clint oh we're getting levels you're
good
i mean so did you hear what i said
though like uh let's reveal the top five
and i feel like in our debate
about which one should get first second
third fourth and fifth
all of that will come out you're right
you're right
okay so here we go announcing the top
five
first off uh carlos i appreciate you
donald i appreciate you i better not
mess this up huh
julia i appreciate you as well uh
julianne julian you're the first top
fiver
congratulations uh more you're gonna win
more on that in a second you're gonna
win something uh juicy
my goodness you came close clay top five
buddy
congratulations loic
amazing he came darn close
lucas came darn close
wait was lucas not in top five i don't
think so
no look at the list
hold on let me double check double check
here
you can't be doing this to me red this
top five
i i thought i remember it was in the top
five too
hold on i may be screwed up
no you're right yeah you're you're right
you're right
you texted me a photo of the topic yeah
i can't find it now
it's in the group chat it
just to be sure it's not in there right
i texted you guys the five
i'm looking at yeah no you're right it's
not
okay god dang ren you're giving me
giving me the shakes here
all right yeah we're still moving on
still moving on
um
so lucas that's how close you came um
nidhish
very very close but pearson is a top
fiver
congrats pearson sam faulkner
very darn close
sergey oh very very close my friend
uh but stefan gets it
top five for stefan and top five for
steven or stefan so that is our top five
um the underwater you go to you yeah
gigi to all you guys
um holy crap let's go through these top
five
and figure out how
we're gonna order these top five um
because it's gonna be
it's gonna be a deal here so the chat is
probably freaking out
right now and also being like what how
could this not get top five
y'all it was like you know
um we all had our food we all had our
favorites
we all have our favorites exactly none
of us agreed
on any of this it was hard to come to a
conclusion
there was no clear winner there was
nothing that was uniformly like yeah
this one's a clear
winner uh they're all all of these top
five
i mean yeah it's gonna take some debate
here to figure out this order now okay
by the time you reach like the top
15 it was like these are just these are
it
these are these are so good the chat's
going crazy like fff
i know they're all so good they're all
so freaking good guys
oh that's funny water sucker should have
won
wait what is f does that mean there no
respects
like respect to all the effects it's
another way of saying r.i.p
rest in peace yeah all right
so there is gonna be no like it's not
official until it's official
so bear with us all right here's what i
think
i think this one is first place
um yo can you go through and figure out
what our number one pick
is yeah okay okay okay our personal
number all right doesn't mean anything
i'm gonna yeah in our hearts there is no
official winner yet
all right well these are the five
winners but we need to figure out the
order because the prizes get crazy
um yeah what's what's our
what's our top what's our number one
do we each want to go through ours or do
one each
for me it's this one this is number one
for me
i'm accounting for story render quality
lighting use of the mocap uh
um what is it uh composition
uniqueness okay um ian what do you got
um my first one this one last plant
it's just every time i see it i just
want to keep like looking in at it
everything was given was given attention
like the render's clean
the designs are are cool um
the paint or the plant looks painterly
uh
everything that could be thought out it
seems like it was thought out yeah i
this is number one for me because and
again it's not official yet
but this is number one for me because it
has story
this story is freaking awesome i love
how deep it goes the more you look
the the design on it is top-notch the
world building is top-notch
um the color the composition
the render quality like the materials
everything about this is like so
freaking good
so that's that's my number one pick uh
peter what do you think
dude i had mine and then you started
talking about that one
and now i'm looking okay stick with
yours no no no no no no no
you have to you're the it evolves and
changes you know what i'm saying so like
so it was harvest but now the more i
look at this one the more i'm amazed by
it
although i could see harvest as number
two
simply because okay it uh it is like
the stalinhag vibe and it's like
no harvest is my number two it's just
it's so it's like perfect
in harvest is my number one because like
the characters the posing the vibe
the atmosphere the tonality the dynamic
range all the invisible lights that were
placed to like catch the edge of
vehicles and like rim light things and
highlight certain things
it's just brilliant in every way so
that's my top
uh red what do you think at this at the
same time like
it is just so stalin hog
that's also true absolutely fantastic
but like is very much somebody else's
style just kind of brought in for for
their own work
yeah that's a good point that's like
that is a good one when i when i did i
did a big old list
with a number like a tally thing and
originality was one of the things on
that list
and this definitely rated lower than
like
this one you know yeah um so like this
gets
this gets an originality point for me
versus this one
um you know that's a good point i was
pretty tired on them but
i i'm gonna give you guys a direct
reference to simon stalin
so i'm gonna go with the uh
the last plant ren what do you think so
i already have my top five picked out
okay
you want me to say it or just tell you
what's your number one
number one is the the warrior walking
through the field
i uh i don't know it's like
i'm not even that big of like a middle
ages
warrior type deal like that's not like
something i i
naturally vibe with but i feel like
it it's one of the most creative uses of
the prompt
and i feel like it's just so perfectly
executed on all fronts
it's it's technically good but it's also
beautiful you know it's it looks like
a painting in motion and uh
just the use of arrows like it also
feels like a shot straight out of a
movie or a show you know it's like it i
i feel like there's there's like a
character struggle going on here that i
can just i
i can see it i can feel it but my second
place
is the last plant okay
yeah this one i've come around to
initially i was a little less
uh on it you know like i was just kind
of like i mean it's cool but
it what i don't know it's been reading
to me more and more the longer i look at
it and it's just so well done it
it looks like all of the different
elements for it are all so
uh intentional you know like it doesn't
feel kit-bashed
yeah it feels like everything that i'm
seeing was made for this even if it
wasn't you know like maybe some of those
background elements are
kit bashed uh rails and and pipes and
stuff thrown together but
everything in the foreground looks like
it was either modeled or specifically
tweaked
and the the character looks originally
created the the
the way the curve of the glass is you
know it's like
that jar okay so i think we can like
safely say for now it's not official yet
but i think we can safely say that this
last
plant is safe to chill in the first
place spot for now because
it's me and ian's first peter is it your
first or second
it's my first okay and it's wren's
second so i think it's chilled
to chill in the first place spot for now
until something we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna figure it out okay
okay so here's here's a here's a
different approach for this next
last place
let's pretend we can only keep four
which one goes the green screen
you think it's the green screen
green screen or green screen or
green screen or star wars star wars
market however
my market is the one that gets to go for
me for for me too i
i love it obviously yeah
this one i think the only thing that
bothers me is
the wall on the left and the ground
plane
the ground plane is very much feels like
a single texture
without much you know uh a great
variety in displacement and i can see
like some rocks flipping through the
ground a little bit
and there's there's a lot of light on
that wall
that feels a little empty and that's the
only thing that's throwing me off about
this one
um here's what i like about this one i
like how it guides your eye throughout
the scene
i like the uh the subtle use
of colors it's not too saturated i like
how it actually feels
like a live thriving market
um i like how these characters feel
unique in the foreground
and the background um i
love that there is
enough story like this i will admit the
story isn't quite there
it's not 100 there for me um
last place i don't know like versus the
green screen
for me i think the render quality is the
worst
of the five yes the render quality is
the worst of the five
dang i was thinking it was i don't know
maybe it's because it feels so
realistic like this one feels the most
realistically rendered
this feels like everything else has a
bit more of a uh a style to it but this
one has like a reality style that i
think weird because i feel like this has
a
video game style and these have movie
styles these are movies
and this one is a video game i is the
way i feel see that one this one reels
like i
this one feels like i whipped out my
iphone and got a shot in a room
same yeah yeah this feels like standing
in the back that's what i mean when i
feel
real but here's the thing i'm also way
more down for like
fantastic worlds like this dramatic
vibey worlds than just like a green
screen room personally
yeah i don't know but it is like this i
just think it's its own
concept so far uh second peter
i just think it takes its own concept so
far and the amount like the density of
jokes
is great and the references to
i mean it's it's perfect for us because
we're all in this world and so we're
like oh i get all these jokes
you know it it it speaks to me so
loudly that it's like someone has like a
freaking speakerphone next to my head
that's funny um this was my personal
number three and it was actually kind of
going for number two
this was my number three this would be
my number if it's not like if it's not
the fifth place for me
it would have to be fourth place like i
i think
who but okay i mean we're trying to
figure out a fifth place right now and i
think uh we're all leaning towards the
the little market uh pearson's one is
number five right
so you guys feel you guys feel that this
one
is fifth place but ren who feels
strongly this is fifth place
i feel strongly that this is fifth place
i don't know about strongly
but but yeah that's that's what happened
yes okay
all right that's fair that's fair let's
let's
work it into that fifth place spot
pearson get you in that fifth place spot
we'll revisit we're gonna revisit we'll
do a final check in here before we call
it
but right now we got pearson in fifth
place we got stephen in first place and
we have to figure out the order
of uh second third and fourth
now personally so let's personally this
is the way i would do it
i would say this is me this is me
fourth place with with
with the stretcher fourth fourth sorry
sorry second place
second place right here harvest gets
second place i would
you can go through yeah i would say
steven stefan
third place with the warrior and then i
would say
fourth place with the green screen
that's me personally
so
you're 100 on that okay
all right uh red what do you got
i uh i think the uh gobacco one the
harvest one yeah harvest that's my
number four that's your fourth you think
that's fourth place
crazy okay how come
i don't know it doesn't resonate as well
as the others but it has story and it
has a render quality and it has like
beautiful composition and like the
lighting is incredible
yeah and i like the lighting and
composition and story and everything
about the others as well i don't know
i'm just saying from a personal
standpoint
this one doesn't res resonate as
strongly as the warrior
or the green screen okay
i from my personal judgment point of
view it is awesome it is a top five
contender here but in my point of view
it's fourth place behind the green
screen the warrior
and the last plane okay so you're you're
saying warrior second place
green green screen third place harvest
fourth place and then the like star wars
world
fifth place that would be my order um
ian what do you got
yeah mine is really similar it's uh
harvest is second
uh warriors sorry sorry um green screen
oh no sorry i'm reading yours i'm
reading
i was like that doesn't sound right um
it's uh
harvest is second green screen is third
warrior is fourth and uh the space
village is fine okay so you would swap
the warrior you think green screen
is uh third place
and the warrior is fourth place yeah
oh boy this is heated okay so me and
peter are
synced up are you still synced up on
this peter
yeah fourth place green screen third
place warrior
second place harvest ian here's the
thing i
the harvest one i do like a lot but i
think the fact that it does hit
way too hard on the stalinhag style
loses some of that originality for me
it's a great execution of that of that
sort of style and concept
uh it's very very good i just don't know
if it deserves second i think the
like i hear you on the stalinhag thing
but i think the story
and the um uh
the story and the lighting beat out
the others the other two like
yeah this it's the story for me on this
one it's like there's so much
like as a piece of art i think this one
stands
uh above the other two
so if not that the other two aren't
[ __ ] i know i know i know
so here's the thing if to be completely
honest
i'm not that attached if you guys want
this one as your second place one
i'm down well i think right now we have
three people saying
harvest as second place um ian and peter
you you think harvest is second place
right
yeah okay i i mean obviously it gets
voted up i i see that i'm just saying i
could be convinced as well
i i just i don't know it was the
lighting didn't impress me as much as it
did you guys on this one
that's fair that's fair i mean that's
the whole thing is like that's the
beauty of having four judges
is like it's a perfect mix of like
of multiple voices it's not just me
choosing it so
so the way you have it ordered right now
with the the far left being fifth place
and the far right being first place
like that looks like a good order to me
i'm i'm down to you know sign off on
that order
so second or fourth and third and fourth
place
between these peter you agree right this
is
very great but but uh ian you have these
flip-flops right
yeah i mean it's it's so close just
like the the medieval one it's it's a
great idea and it's implemented
like perfectly like it is so incredibly
solid uh
the green screen one is just also a
great idea done
perfectly with like all of these
additional little little jokes and
things to discover like
i've been looking at the medieval one uh
a lot and i haven't really seen
anything more than i saw in the first
few seconds
it just continues to be really really
solid where's the green tree the green
screen one kept
there's all these little things kind of
hidden in there and i i don't know
i agree with ian i agree with ian
you guys think uh green screen should be
number three yeah
i'm down two i like it okay well then we
might
sorry stefan he just got demoted stefan
it's chill dude it's chill
wacom tablets they you know
they're they're reasonably priced i'll
say that they're reasonably priced
um uh so this is this i
think so like we have
uh we have pearson in fifth place
stefan in fourth place julian in third
place
clay in second place and
stefan in first place
i feel good about that just drop that
layer down yeah hold on one second here
i feel good about this too it's like i'm
at peace with this selection
so for me green screen um
has uniqueness
um and i just had it on the top of my
head it has uniqueness and story
a bit more than the warrior the warrior
i set beats it out in render quality but
i think in terms of uniqueness and story
the green screen is is better the
warrior also works the best
as a thumbnail out of all of these i
think yeah even
including the first place like looking
at all of these in their small form
there
like the the warrior one like zoom out a
little bit in your timeline i don't i
don't think the rest of the
the audience can see it what's up do
what they can only see the art
like zoom out in the timeline a little
bit so we don't see duplicated images on
the the bars oh
yes yeah there we go so like just look
at
uh an imagery standpoint i feel like the
the warrior is the strongest
in terms of like the like the lighting
and the visual yeah yeah i see you yeah
just like the contrast
the natural vignette going on uh
you know like when we when we review
thumbnails and it's like does this
thumbnail work when i it's literally the
size of my thumb
and you're looking at it across the room
like it's not it's
i'm just throwing out extra details i'm
noticing
uh y'all the chat's going crazy we're
not doing a poll we're not doing a poll
no
we got all of these we got no we're
definitely i'm not i'm not even looking
at the chat if people are suggesting
what should be
it is not yeah we're not doing polls
y'all like we
we we got the best group of people
together
we have put hours and hours and hours
and hours of thought into this and this
is what it is so
we actually legit have at this point
yeah um
so pearson congratulations you got fifth
place
buddy um you are getting yeah
a year-long quixote mega scans
subscription
and you're also gonna get a really cool
pny ssd
um staphon fourth place congratulations
you're getting the same exact thing the
year-long subscription of
uh qixel mega scans and also you will be
getting
a pny ssd julian congratulations buddy
hold up hold up huh
what fourth and fifth place prizes are
the same yes yes yes
yeah uh julian you are getting
the year-long quixote mega scan
subscription you are also getting
uh a more advanced pny ssd it's way
faster
and you're also getting a wacom tablet
of your choice um
small medium or large whatever you want
congratulations we love your stuff
clay congrats on second place you're
getting the quixote mega scan
subscription
uh you're getting the super fast pny ssd
you're also getting a wacom tablet
you're also getting
a pair of these bone conduction
headphones i love these things
they're uh open ear headphones you can
go on hikes and listen to something
called aftershocks yeah because we
always just
phone phones yeah um and finally
the grand prize all that other stuff
plus a full rococo motion capture suit
along with
the gloves and their studio pro for
about a year i believe is what it is
yeah you're getting all that stuff dude
um
stefan stefan congratulations on first
place you
freaking deserve it um freaking sick man
congratulations to all five you guys who
won congrats to all top hundred
who made this whole video um and
congrats to everyone
everybody yes yeah
i mean taking a month to do something
and like
and actually delivering not many people
can say they've done that um it's a hard
thing to do it's a hard thing to stick
to
even myself with my render right now i'm
having a hard time finishing it
it's like okay no i need to i will
two weeks there'll be a breakdown on it
but now that we're
done i can now take a step back
readjust context switch out of like
judgement picking mode and now i'm just
like oh my god they're so amazing now i
want to actually watch all 2 400 of them
so that comes out next week you had a
few in the in the the the
intro video to the stream you're showing
a few that didn't make it into the top
100
and i was looking at and i was like dang
these are all really good
they must have just barely not made it
to the top 100. seriously yeah
um there's a lot myself and the
moderators went through
and you know went through and freaking
picked the top 100 and it was really
hard because there's a lot of solid
renders
this is a very difficult process i'm
shaking i'm nervous
that wasn't i feel like so many of these
renders are just like the best thing
that so many people
have have made like more creative energy
has been dumped
into all of these things than i've seen
in one place in like
forever 18 years this is incredibly
special exactly
um so next week we have a top 100
montage
with custom music by my my boy feverkin
he wrote two tracks for it
top 100 all these vendors we went
through you're going to see him in a
montage with some sick music
i'm going to put everyone's names and
social medias on it so you can follow
all these artists
and uh also coming out that same
saturday
is going to be the full 2401 cut
everything three and a half hours of
every single submission
all with the freaking uh with the credit
the social medias and the names attached
so you can find any artist you want
that's going to come out uh this next
saturday one week from now
uh i have a lot of names to type up and
that's why i had you guys include your
names
in the prod in the file name so i can
see it
huh yeah yeah that's clutch having in
the actual file name you don't have to
cross-reference anything
congrats everybody seriously everybody
someone says they didn't understand the
18 years thing
but every person who submitted something
you ask them to also submit how much
time they worked on
for that some people were putting 10
hours some people were putting 100 hours
and you tallied up all of the hours
total and it
totaled up to 18 years worth of
hours yep it's unbelievable we could
have raised a kid with all that work
i know that's older than like probably
half the people who submitted
that's crazy and that's like pure
non-stop work no break no no
vacations yeah um i gotta say thank you
to you guys for taking the time that
probably took a little longer than we
planned for
um i really really appreciate it thank
you so much
um and to the moderators do you guys up
in here thank you guys to my moderators
for keeping the chat tame thank you chat
everybody in the chat for
chilling out with us and having a good
time and if you guys didn't win
i got basically all the companies that
provided
uh prizes they gave like 15 10
some 50 off discount codes in the
description so you guys can like
you know if you were thinking about
getting one of those things anyway they
wanted to provide like a little little
discount code for y'all so you can hit
that up
so like the top 100 nice yeah everyone
everyone anyone who clicks anyone
yes anyone um
yeah other than that uh i'm probably
gonna just use the restroom and chill
with with the chat for another
10 or 15 minutes before i call it um but
you guys
feel free to hang out but you guys have
spent too much time
doing this already
our skype call is at four hours and 43
minutes right now
wow yeah that sounds about right um on
and off of like 12 olives
oh my god you've been eating olives this
whole time
yeah oh my god not gonna lie i i if
we're if we're done here i think i'm
gonna go
get out what did ren what are you doing
here get out go
this is incredible honestly clint thank
you so much for inviting me to be a
judge on this i feel honored to have
been a part of this
i thought about even submitting
something of my own i didn't have the
time to actually put any
effort into something so i was going to
try to just like
make the low lowest effort most
insultingly
stupid entry but then i was like no
that's
no i i really appreciate man thank you
guys for i'm happy to have been in
involved in the way i was this is very
cool pretty much
everyone in the top 100 submitted
something that i feel i could not have
competed with
and so that's how good everything was
from my point of view it was just
incredible like every single child was
like man that i don't know how to do
that or man
i wouldn't have thought to do that it
was just everything was incredible
the end thank you so much for having me
on thank you ren for taking the time
especially on your vacation weekend
all of you guys yeah we can thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
peter thank you ian you guys are the
best
love you just excited to see what you do
next time
dude it's serious yeah i'm excited for
the next one this is this was a really
big one
i imagine you're going to give it a
little bit more time before you do
another not true
it's going to be way faster than you
think it's coming way faster
really oh it's the next week it's not
next week it's not next week but it's
very soon
um yeah clint this was this was really
special i
i feel honored like wren said to be a
part of this you know just
seeing everybody in the 3d community who
usually we're all in our own little
niches and our own subreddits but seeing
everybody come together into this one
thing was
really cool and something i've never
seen before so kudos to you
thanks man and thanks to freaking all
you guys who submitted
who made this a thing because i
obviously there would be nothing if you
guys didn't
submit to this and like i'm just putting
the videos together you know
like but i appreciate it
thank you peter thank you ian oh yeah
it's been fun chilling with the boys
yeah
go enjoy your weekends go enjoy your
weekends have a good one guys
go eat the restaurant yeah have a good
one see you guys watching everyone i
appreciate all of you too
i'm amazing amazing amazing jobs peace
out y'all i'm a chill with the chat here
but um you guys have a good one enjoy
the weekends all right
take care peace out
and then there was one
oh
boy oh boy that was intense
ugh
y'all thank you for hanging out with me
oh that was quite the stream huh
i need to use the restroom um
i can't wait to show you guys all this
all this art back to back it's going to
be crazy
um so a couple things i'm just a couple
announcements
i'm going to take a two minute break use
the restroom and i'll come back i'll
answer any questions you guys have hang
out with you guys for another 15 minutes
or so if you guys
you know a little post-mortem um but
that was incredible obviously couldn't
have done this whole thing without you
guys
uh thank you to the sponsors for
providing awesome
awesome content and awesome uh see my
i'm brain dead at this point
awesome prizes for the top five winners
um
if you guys didn't win it's all good i
know there were some really cool prizes
this time around
but i hope if you entered this thing
that you learned something and you grew
over this last month because that's
exactly what this whole stream is for
it's for all of us to learn and grow
together
in our passions and for me right now my
passion among
other passions is vfx 3d work
world building lighting uh telling
stories
making movies that's what i want to do
so
i get to do it every week with you guys
and get better at it i don't know all
the answers
i don't know how to do all the tricks in
the book i know a couple tricks
and i've learned a lot from you guys
i've learned a lot from this chat every
week we get together
right now we're at 2 800
live viewers which is double
what i've ever had and that's freaking
amazing if you guys are new to this
channel and if you liked what you saw
this was very this was different you
know we're reviewing art
um definitely subscribe if you guys
aren't subscribed already
uh if you guys like the content check
out the channel um
watch a couple videos the whole point is
to learn and grow together
in our passions vfx 3d passions
i usually like to keep it pretty chill
this stream in particular was pretty
intense
um i've had the most technical
difficulties i've ever had on a live
stream it's also the biggest live stream
i've ever done
it was also the most pressure on a live
stream for me personally so
it was very uh lots of anxiety
and stress and i'm glad i get to
chill out right now um because it was
very stressful that first hour with all
the
lagging and stuff i'm glad we got it
figured out uh we peaked at 6k
heck yeah amazing
but i gotta just shout outs to you guys
for for hanging out with me and hanging
out all the way i know it's late for a
lot of y'all um
i just hope you guys learned something i
hope you guys are able to take a little
bit of this knowledge
and and apply it to your own work apply
it to your own art
and you know not everyone is going to
agree with the top
five winners that myself ian peter and
ren chose
i get that i get that and if it was
like if it was up to just one person
the results would probably be a little
bit different um
not very different maybe a little bit
different but
i wanted to keep it as broad as possible
that's why i wanted to bring peter ian
and renon
is to have a less biased opinion a less
biased view
of all these renters so
i would just congratulate all you guys
you know i don't want to knock anybody
for not winning i don't want to say oh
they should have got third they should
have fourth like
that's totally okay and it's okay for
you guys to have your opinion on that
um as we myself ian peter we all had our
different opinions that's
totally fine um but shout outs to
pearson stefan julian
clay and stefan there's two stefan
stefan
um for winning this thing i'll be in
contact with you guys
send you some emails 3 24 a.m
for gar of uh thanks for hanging in for
so long
how are you guys doing how's everyone
you guys hanging in
thumbs ups thanks for chilling with me
you guys are hanging out almost midnight
for alessandro
if you guys have any questions for me
hit me up with uh
with a little app punisher when is my
render coming
good question i got a render i did you
know a little submission
um in the next two weeks so next weekend
is going to be these montages the 100
top 100 montage with custom music by my
buddy feverkin
you can look them up on spotify if you
guys want to check them out beforehand
and then also uh there's the top 2401
renders it's gonna be a three and a half
hour long video
with everything so both of those come
out next weekend
the following weekend i'm gonna do a
really nice
chill breakdown of my render of my
submission for this thing
uh if you guys saw my uh my mortality
run
you know art breakdown with the car in
the ocean with the oil rigs in the back
if you saw me do that
it's gonna be very similar to that so
that's the next two weeks
definitely subscribe if you guys want to
catch that if you want to catch the top
100 montage the 2401 montage
subscribe to the channel like the video
leave a comment you know you guys have
been on youtube you know i do this stuff
ah oh man i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
soldier through i'm gonna chill with
y'all for the next 15 minutes and then
i'm gonna use the bathroom
and then i'm gonna eat some food um
so i see some questions coming in what
do we got i'm just gonna i'm looking at
the ones with at punisher
all right it's just a little easier for
me to see here
um sotomonte do we have a weekly
challenge for next week
hadn't even thought of it yet um
so there's a i have a discord server
right
the link is in the description and it's
a community of 3d artists for all of us
to challenge and push ourselves this is
a month-long challenge we just did
usually we do weekly challenges much
smaller much more chill
and i review those at the end of every
live stream i do
and yes we will be getting back to
weekly challenges i will probably
announce the weekly challenge
uh tomorrow i am wiped right now
so maybe i'll get something up later
today maybe i'll get something up
tomorrow definitely
by tomorrow for sure but yeah we'll be
doing weekly challenges again
and it's a fun little submission process
i break down to a lot of honorable
mentions here on the stream pick five
winners there's no prizes it's just to
learn and grow together different little
prompts for every week
um steven grimm holy crap
the first place winner thank you so much
really appreciate the feedback really
crazy i didn't expect to be top 100
you freaking won dude
that's insane i'll be sending you a
rococo mocap suit a wacom tablet
bone conduction headphones qixel mega
scans
pny ssds dude you're going to be popping
off
heck yeah um willing
i have a question you stack two lasagnas
on top of each other are they separate
lasagnas or one big lasagna
in your opinion i'd say one big lasagna
if they were cooked together if they're
cooked
out the oven then stacked after it's
been plated
that's two lasagnas on top of each other
for sure
pelinio clint will the download of the
project
will keep will you keep it available i
want to do a version of my own um
i will have that available to you guys
i'm gonna have
basically i'm gonna announce it next
week
um i'm starting a patreon i'm starting a
patreon next week
um it's not live yet but i'm gonna going
to announce that
uh with the montage videos i think on
that
you guys will have access to basically
everything all my downloaded files
all my assets all my project
files um all of my
you know surface imperfections any
product i would ever sell would be there
for free
um i'm going to get into it a little bit
more on exactly
what the patreon will look like but
that'll be announced
next week that kind of stuff will stuff
still be available
it'll probably all be on the patreon it
just depends maybe
i'll have the product i should probably
have the project file just for free
i think that's probably the best way to
go just have it up for free like an
archive on the discord server the
discord is free you don't need to be on
a patreon or anything
it's just a free discord link's in the
description
um good question no yeah we should
probably have that available to all you
guys
so just mess with and play around with
is the next challenge this summer
yes the next challenge is this summer
it's going to be announced a lot sooner
than you would think
another reason to subscribe if you guys
want to be a part of this awesome
challenge with some prizes
um we're going to do a little different
uh this next time
different little concept different
camera
mix it up a little bit you know the last
two we did are people walking
nah no people in this one it's gonna be
cool
what else do we got we got a lot of a
lot of questions up in here
uh the countdown render was like top 150
no the countdown render
like basically um
here let me let me play it for you let's
see here let me just play it for you
real quick
very briefly very very briefly
[Music]
so that last one there that was dizzy
vipers one
with like the uh the like desert sand
with the eyeball
and the outhouse getting blown away that
was dizzy vipers
um no that's just a random collection of
the 2400 that i just quickly dropped in
to make that countdown that's not top
150 it's just
random picks you know um
thank you guys for all the super chats
my god i couldn't get back to you guys
on all of those because it was just such
a hectic stream
trying to fix all the technical goodness
technical difficulties
um my dying channel shout outs to you
thank you for the super chat you made
top 15. you were the claustrophobic
corridor one the claustrophobic corridor
one
which one is that
claustrophobic corridor
i don't recall top 15.
uh i'm sure
i will recognize it when i see it
but congrats congrats i'm brain dead at
this point dude
we went for how long how do we go for
four hours
that's a lot that's a lot um so one
thing
oh the zombies yo yes the zombie one
dude
did you hand animate those did you hand
animate those zombies because that was
nuts
absolutely insane tadpole thank you for
the super chat
i really appreciate you guys thank you
for the support it means a lot
jae chen yes jae chen
from pny dude um shout outs to jay
by the way um for hooking up the pny
prizes
jay thank you so much man freaking
awesome
thank you for the five dollars i will
get a kombucha for sure
i will need one after this um
man that was a long stream that was a
really long stream what else are you
gonna say
um oh yeah if you guys also want to help
out another another fun way to help out
is to click that skillshare link down in
like the top of the
description it's actually a legit way to
learn
um it's a paid service fairly fairly
cheap
um to get like curated tutorial videos
for vfx and all that stuff
so definitely check the skillshare link
it helps i think it's free for you guys
to sign up for
uh i think like a two-week trial or
something and it also
helps me because skillshare is like oh
yeah you got a bunch of people to click
and check out her stuff so
good for you we'll keep working together
um
so that's a good one oh yeah cg geek
also
did a submission uh steve
and his was in let's see let me actually
show you
let me show you i'll show you steve's
real quick cg geeks render
um
look at ren look at red on the freeze
frame
oh that's funny um
here are a couple renders that may
get very close let me render these real
quick for you guys
so this was a very close to top 100
um this guy here was very very close to
top 100
we had this guy uh close to top 100
they're going to be a little laggy
most likely andre
with uh berserk
a little berserk render this is a really
good world war two one with some story
i like that one a lot same here world
war ii
with the vibes very nice um
this one here i really liked the like
the visual composition i thought it was
really well done
i love the lighting on this one i just
thought the moon could have been
brighter
and this one is thieves cg steve
cg geek yeah
he's got like the avatar floating
planets and actually he actually put out
a video
of his breakdown for this if you want to
check that out uh cg geek's
channel very very cool and then yeah
this is like a little gold miner
really fun idea and uh
this guy here this is an unreal engine
all real time and unreal engine a little
laggy just because it's 4k
but yeah those are the ones that uh they
got very very close they almost won
uh almost got top 100 yeah
uh so dude okay back to the zombie horde
one
you actually hand animated every single
one
um
that is believable here
so this is hand animated all those
characters dude
such a good idea shout outs to you man
julia
sorry if you are a woman i apologize
but it's hard to tell just by the name
um but that's so good
it's so good the hand animated
characters are ridiculous
so good it makes it even better the fact
that it's hand animated
jackson i see you thank you for the
super chat really appreciate you man
you said would i be willing to do a one
hour challenge or something like that i
did with people yeah we've done these on
the channel before
um we've done like a two hour challenge
where we do it together so it's
you guys i'll give you the assets and we
make something cool we'll do that soon
absolutely we'll do that very soon i
think that's a really fun way to go
um i got a couple more super chats here
thank you guys for the support it means
a lot
let's turn down my iso real quick
[Music]
um tadpole says wow what a what a knight
top 15. thank you so much for that
that's absolutely amazing i made the
alien chip that sucked up the water
such a cool idea man such a cool idea
that was my favorite background element
um freaking awesome man thank you for
the super chat
thank you for the support thanks for
hanging out with me uh evolver
back at it again dude i saw you um
earlier with a super chat
thank you for the support once again
uh i'll be hitting you up to render my
submission i'm going to figure out some
like render network to get it rendered
in time
but thanks for the support man carlos i
see you thank you for the super chat
it says surreal that i made it to top 15
seemed like the render was darker on
stream than originally submitted any
advice resolving that in the future
so that could be the codec carlos that
could be the codec
um and the way
it's imported into da vinci potentially
yeah it's it's tough if it's like a
lossless kind of a codec or if it's like
a
uh like a like a prores file it might do
that to you
it's also it's hard to tell yeah it's
hard to tell but i just
dropped everything in maybe it was
darker
we'll figure that one out um definitely
i don't want to mess with anyone's stuff
also i don't want to like tweak their
settings and
brighten it up or saturate it or make it
darker i just want to have it as
is and having all these clips coming to
da vinci as an auto
clip um is the safest bet for me
um but apologies carlos if it was
brighter
um peter thanks for the super chat no
message necessary just the support man i
appreciate you
i need to check my video on youtube i
don't understand revolver you're scaring
me what do you mean i gotta check my
video on youtube
uh nathaniel thank you would i do a
challenge for a broader set of art
styles like 2d animation quarter type
videos claymation stop motion
i don't know maybe maybe
um we could do something fun like that i
like mixing it up i don't like doing
just the same thing over and over again
um i'm always for mixing it up so that
sounds like a good one to me
noah thank you sir for the support um
you say thank you for the challenge
absolutely i got you i'm just trying to
get you guys making some cool stuff you
know
any excuse to make some cool stuff the
better right he said you learned a lot
amazing you made the lego waterfall
render that didn't make top 100
but was still proud heck yeah man your
render was good
and you will see it in the full montage
next week
next saturday
get a haircut i need a haircut don't i
i do need a haircut
in time in time
um when great challenge
glad to meet the community on discord
learned a lot and we'll keep learning
um heck yeah heck yeah
keep it up absolutely
um it's all about surrounding yourself
with a
supportive community like this guys it
really is
um it would be pretty boring to just do
it on your own
and i know a lot of us are either young
with not a lot of friends who are
into 3d or we maybe the area you live
you don't have a lot of people around
you that you can like it's not la you
know in la there's every there's so much
going on but wherever you guys are from
like you guys can hop into this
community the internet is an amazing
thing isn't it
we can hop into this community together
and make some cool stuff
so i'm glad that you guys are happy to
be a part of it i'm glad that you guys
are happy to be learning a lot
big fan from india dude it's early in
india right now shout outs man
carlos yeah dude uh you said thanks for
the advice again appreciate all you did
look forward to the next one
i do too yeah
um milan thank you for the super chat i
appreciate you
uh it was so fun to see the whole 3d
community come together yes
yes i agree guys i really think this is
the biggest internet
challenge ever it's the biggest 3d
challenge that the internet has ever
seen and i think the montage that i'm
going to put out is going to show how
big this challenge is it's freaking
crazy
18 years worth of total collective work
hours
it was a one month challenge we got 2401
submissions and it
the total work hours equal 18 years
freaking crazy absolutely crazy
evolver says those who submit videos to
youtube need to test the codec
beforehand youtube does funky things
hmm i just get stressed out that the
stream is bad
i get stressed out that i'm having more
technical difficulties i'm gonna have
nightmares man
goodness
uh jalen thank you i'm glad you liked
the videos man
you had a stuntman 82 how to cancel
their haircut appointment to watch the
stream
dang thank you thank you so much that's
sick
i hope you can get a haircut i need to
get a haircut too
um jackson have you done a challenge
that involved
vr as in not just edited in but to be
viewed in vr i have not yet
but i do have plans for a very fun vr
experience that i want to
release uh the end of this year you guys
will if you're subscribed to the channel
you'll probably see me working on it on
the weekly live streams
usually i'm working on stuff versus
reviewing art but i do a little art
review at the end of each one as well
and uh indie story dude
yo thank you for the support thanks for
the super chat
um he said you dropped in again to thank
you for helping this challenge
get set up i got you man no worries glad
you made it the top 50.
the winner deserved it for sure yeah man
cheers thank you thank you man
thank you for guys look you guys made
this
awesome like the art that you put into
this
and the fact that you guys put all of
your effort
and best work into this challenge makes
the top 100 montage
like the coolest it can possibly be
the harder you guys put in the more work
you guys put in
to your individual pieces the more
powerful
the montage gets you know what i'm
saying and the 2400 in one montage
is going to be one of the most powerful
things ever um
so i can't wait to frickin show you guys
that cannot wait
will there be a live stream next week so
here's my plan
the top hundred montage i'm gonna
release that video maybe nine
maybe 10 a.m i don't know the
2401 montage
i might make a mic uh i'll i'll make it
as a youtube like live premiere
video where like the video goes up but
it's also a live stream
for just the duration of the video and
once the video is over it's not a live
stream anymore
i might do it that way i might just like
have a beer and chill and
kick back and watch some renters with
you guys that's probably the way i'll do
it
that's my plan that's my plan yes there
is a challenge coming soon
another one another community challenge
um it'll almost
be back-to-back challenges here it's
going to be a lot
but it's going to be a good one it's
going to be a very very good one
how many submissions do i think there
will be next time i don't i couldn't
even say
i couldn't even say no idea
if i could guess how big the final file
would be with all 2400 videos
god 10 gigs
maybe 20 12 gigs i don't know it'd be a
lot
um did i see the renders that were that
were late
to the deadline or did i just discard
them i did see them
i truly went through every render
this is this is just for peace of mind
for you guys
and kind of for myself too there was a
couple
pardon there's a couple renders that
relate
that um like if your render was late you
can't make it to the top hundred montage
right um but i went through and i
chose from the 2401 that's including the
late ones i chose the top hundred
and i made sure that um basically
you know if if it was late in the top
hundred it couldn't happen
right so i managed to
just get the top hundred as the rangers
that came in on time
and then anything else um it couldn't
win
it couldn't win um but i will show it in
the 2401 montage
that is that is a thing for sure
oh guys i think it might be it might be
time to call it
um last little announcements here
i'll see you guys next week for the
awesome montages i'm putting together
um what else if you guys
didn't win and you want to purchase you
know some of these
bone phones or you want to purchase a uh
qixel mega scan subscription 50 off that
i got actually got some notes for you
here we go
so rococo i got you guys 10 off
all rococo products until june 11th use
rkk
underscore punisher um
all this stuff is in the description
okay quicksole all right
uh if you use the code pone21 50 off
your first month of mega scans
for the first 3000 people that expires
june 8th
three days and then for aftershocks
these bone conduction headphones
this is the freaking move right here
uh 15 off all products and i believe
it's the tech 37j
is the discount code all that stuff is
in the description
and that's just like the these companies
did not reach out to me
and pay me to say any of this stuff i
reached out to these companies i reached
out to rococo i reached out to wacom
to uh aftershocks to pny and to qixel
because i wanted the prize pool to be
built up from
all the stuff i use every day i use this
stuff
every single day um so i wanted to
you know reward the winners with all the
tools that i use all the time
so i reached out to these guys and
they're like yo if you guys want to
you know for people who don't win check
out the stuff in the description you
know
a little 15 10 50
just for you guys i appreciate y'all
yeah i i need to use the restroom i need
to use the restroom
i'm going to bounce um thank you for
hanging out with me
thanks for hanging out with me guys that
was a long one wasn't it
i'll see you guys next week the goal is
saturday 4 200
and now 2401
montage as a premier video
which means i'll just live stream and
watch it with you guys that's the plan
for next saturday
along with the top 100 you guys are
amazing
thank you for your time thank you for
your energy thank you for
sticking around with me um for hanging
out
it's been a crazy year i was able to
leave corridor digital to do all this
stuff full time because you guys kept
coming back
and that means a lot it really does so
you guys enjoy your weekend if you're in
india go to bed
or you know let's get moving it's the
early morning right now
i appreciate you guys um i feel like i'm
just rambling at this point
i'm gonna get some food i'm gonna go for
a one-wheel ride
and i'm gonna use the bathroom
peace out guys thank you moderators
ronan i see you
visual i saw you up in here sodamonte
shout outs peace out guys see you next
week
subscribe if ain't subscribe have a good
weekend be safe
stay creative be passionate later y'all
oh you all get the ending screen hold on
i almost cut it out on you right there
[Music]
you